5, 4, 3, 2, 1 und los geht's! Ja, wir sind abgehoben. Also wir sind sowieso immer ziemlich abgehoben, aber trotzdem, selbst wenn man dauerhaft abgehoben ist, muss man auch einfach manchmal nochmal abheben. Und das könnten wir jetzt eigentlich mal machen, oder? Genau, schlechte Witze, entspannte Stimmung. Ihr wisst, wo ihr seid. Ihr seid bei MobileMacs, dem Podcast, wo es über viele unwichtige Sachen geht. Und noch nie waren sie, glaube ich, so unwichtig wie dieses Mal, weil wir uns wieder in so einem Newsloch befinden. Ich habe auch nochmal unsere üblich verdächtigen Nachrichten-Zuträger abgeklappert und muss feststellen, es ist wirklich eine Zeit der Gerüchte, des Grüpelns. Sommerloch ist gar kein Ausdruck. Es ist ein schwarzes Loch des Sommers. Ein Sommerschwarzloch. Und jetzt könnten wir natürlich den Fehler machen, uns auch genauso in diese Gerüchteküche mit einklinken, wie es mal gerne so getan wird. Na ja, wir könnten darüber mutmaßen, was jetzt als nächstes rauskommt. Wir könnten mutmaßen, was das iPhone alles für tolle Feature kriegen würde. Wollen wir damit anfangen?
Wenn wir schon mal keine Themen haben, müssen wir alles greifen, was uns anbietet.
Ich hab schon ein paar Themen aufgeschrieben. Wir können ja erstmal zurückblicken. Und zwar ist ja nicht so, dass nichts passiert ist. Letztes Mal haben wir ja auch groß noch angekündigt. Kannst du mal das Return bitte nicht so hart drücken, Max? Republika.
Republika?
Wir waren da. Wir waren auf einer verschrienen Konferenz, wo viele Leute, die nicht da waren, der Meinung waren, das wäre alles ganz furchtbar. Ernsthaft? Jaja, da gab es wieder Schreihilse.
Ah, die habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ja.
Irgendwie habe ich während der Republik, war das Web so irgendwie so, es war nicht so anwesend. Ja, ich habe so gedacht, hey, ich surf gar nicht so viel rum wie sonst normalerweise.
Ja, ich habe viel dummes Zeug gelesen. Dummes Zeug von Leuten, die auch sonst eigentlich viel dummes Zeug reden und dann sich halt irgendwie auch die Republiker wieder vorgenommen haben. Ich meine, man kann an den Republikern schon das ein oder andere herum kritisieren, aber letzten Endes ist es schon irgendwie noch eine ganz interessante Veranstaltung. War auf jeden Fall auch ganz gut besucht hier von unserer Macintosh-Sender-Gemeinde. Ich war, also ein bisschen Bits und so und iPhone-Blog lief herum.
Leo von FesteKarlok habe ich getroffen.
Leo war da, genau. Auch das erste Mal richtig kennengelernt. Sehr netter Mensch und ja, von daher hatten wir auch eine ganze Menge zu mutmaßen und zu diskutieren. Es wurden irgendwie geheime Geräte herum gezeigt und abgesehen davon war es natürlich jetzt kein Macintosh-Event, oder?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Also ich meine es waren, nein, nein, es ist kein Macintosh-Event.
Aber es gab viele Macintoshes auf dem Event.
Ja, also die übliche Menge halt auf solchen Veranstaltungen.
Und du warst nicht da, Dennis? Warum?
Die feiern sich doch alle nur selbst da.
Du solltest einen Blog schreiben.
Ist auch selbst feiern.
Was ist denn nicht selbst feiern?
Zu Hause sitzt nur ein Nerden, während draußen 30 Grad sind.
Da sollst du dich selbst schwitzen.
Das ist in der Tat, naja, er sitzt ja im Dunkeln.
Ich hab ja auch so eine schicke Erdgeschosswohnung mit vielen Schatten.
Und was hast du da gemacht?
Schick und Schatten.
Also ich meine, womit hast du dich dann produktiv auseinandergesetzt?
Na, mein Fernseher geht jetzt wieder. Mein Amiga hat ein neues Kickstart.
Das will ich gar nicht ernsthaft. Du hast für dich Amiga-Installationsarbeiten vorgenommen?
Wie neu?
Wieso, gab es da jetzt auch noch so ein Spiel, wo du alle 150 Levels durchspielen musst, nachdem C64 durch ist?
Aber ich hab gerade so eine Legacy-Phase.
Die dauert aber schon lang.
Und so eine Hardware-Bastelfase. Aber es macht voll Spaß.
Und was kommt dabei raus so?
Mein Fernseher gibt es ja, ich kann meinen Amiga anschließen. Ich hab mir bei eBay einen 64er bestellt und eine Floppy.
Ja.
Ich kann jetzt von diesem Preservation Project alle Originalspiele im Originalzustand auf eine Floppy brennen und dann zocken. Zum Beispiel Outrunner. Mit richtigen Joysticks. Bei dem 64er war ein Quickshot 1 dabei. Kannst du dir das vorstellen?
Ein Quickshot 1 Joystick?
Ja, kennst du noch?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich überhaupt einen Quickshot kenne. Competition Pro war doch immer das, was wir alle haben wollten.
Der kam später.
Später, ich bin ja...
Quickshot klingt auch mehr nach einem Sexspielzeug als nach einem Computerzubehör, oder?
Ich muss mich ja als früh C64er outen. Also bei vielen Leuten, die C64 immer noch so total hip waren, hatte ich die Plattform ja schon wieder verlassen. Ich hab immer so mit Atari-Joysticks gespielt.
Oh ja, von dem 2600 davor, ja.
Ja genau, die immer so abbrachen, wenn man irgendwie zu viele Summergames gespielt hat und so.
Die Caslon.
Da könnte man jetzt ja total tolle Überleitung auf diesen Webbrowser machen.
Das könnten wir tun. Wir haben nämlich dummes Zeug erzählt, Dennis. Beziehungsweise genau genommen hast du dummes Zeug erzählt.
Ich hab erzählt, dass das Load-On-Spiel damals stand immer da broken bei 1103 und da hab ich sogar noch die gleiche Version kann man jetzt immer noch irgendwie runterladen und da hab ich irgendwie geforscht und hab rausgefunden fälschlicherweise, dass dieser 1103-Typ der Typ ist, der den iCapt geschrieben hat und da habt ihr jetzt rausgefunden, dass das wohl falsch ist.
Naja, herausgefunden ist ein bisschen falsch gesagt.
Und das stimmt so halb.
Ich hatte schon so ein bisschen Zweifel, als wir darüber geredet hatten.
Ja, aber ich war nah dran.
Du warst schon nah dran, allerdings. Ich hatte die ganze Zeit das Gefühl, dass es sich nicht um den richtigen Namen handelt, nur vielmehr halt auch der Name so recht nicht ein. Tatsache ist, dass sich der Alexander, der also die iCapt schreibt, sich an uns gewendet hat. Gewandt, gewendet, hat uns eine Mail geschrieben hat. Und dann hat er uns mal so die Geschichte...
Der beweist, dass wirklich Leute unsere Sendung hören.
So müsst ihr das mal sehen.
Das kriegt man auch gut mit, wenn man die Erdgeschosswohnung mal verlässt und mit Leuten spricht.
Stimmt. Auf der Republika zum Beispiel gab es ein paar Hörer.
Echt?
Natürlich.
Na gut.
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall. Hast du das gerade mal präsent?
Ich hab die E-Mail gerade mal offen. Alexander schreibt iCAP. Er hat das aber mit...
Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass es iCAP überhaupt noch gibt.
Genau. Da hat er erzählt, dass es eigentlich ein Browser war, der seine Urzüge auf dem Atari hatte. Und da hat er den Namen CAP, großes C, großes A, großes B, so richtig verkauft von ASH., Application Systems Heidelberg, die dann irgendwann mal als Atari-Pleite gingen, glaube ich, auch auf Mac-Software umgestiegen sind. Das machen sie bis heute. So Real Basic vertreiben die, glaube ich, zum Beispiel. Und dann wollte er selber auf den Mac umgestiegen und hat aber trotzdem weiterhin im Atari-Emulator, es gab ja so einen schicken Atari-Emulator für den Mac, den hatte ich auch mal, hat er da weiterhin seinen Cap-Browser drin laufen lassen. Hatte ihn dann irgendwann mal direkt auf Mac OS portiert. Und zwar auf System 7.5. Weil iCap wird bald 10 Jahre alt.
Echt, so lang ist das schon her.
Und war da jetzt gerade nicht gelesen. Achso, aber der... 1103.
1103.
Okay. Der hat tatsächlich mit ihm zusammen das... Entweder iCap oder Cap gestartet. Das Projekt.
Also er steckt da schon so ein bisschen drin, aber jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht mehr. Und...
Da war es ja dann doch nicht so falsch.
Nein, es war nicht so falsch. Aber die interessante Information ist, iCap gibt es halt noch. Das ist halt so einer von diesen vielen Browsern. Mittlerweile benutzt er halt auch WebKit, mit anderen Worten so das Darstellen von Webseiten ist jetzt gar nicht mehr so sehr das Problem. Und hat halt so sein eigenes spezielles Set an Features, die man jetzt so bei anderen Browsern eben nicht so ohne weiteres findet. So in offline Modus zum Beispiel, wo ich letztes Mal auch noch geklagt habe, dass sowas ja auch nicht so richtig durchgehend da wäre. Sowas hat der zum Beispiel nicht wahr. Und auch noch dieses eigentliche Feature beim iCAP damals, war ja, dass iCAP so der erste Browser war, der ehrlich war, der immer gesagt hat, diese Webseite verstößt gegen die HTML-Richtlinien und einem immer diese ganzen Fehler aufgezeigt hat. Das Feature gibt es halt immer noch. Also bei Design natürlich, warum auch nicht.
Die haben so einen kleinen Smiley drin, man sollte iCAP immer zum Lächeln bringen.
Genau.
Und das war aber relativ kompliziert, muss man auch sagen.
Ja, und er hat da irgendwie nette Sachen, es gibt da unten so eine Button-Leiste in iCAP, wo man sich dann auch irgendwie anzeigen lassen kann, ob irgendwelche Geoinformationen in der Seite drin sind, die SS-Feeds, halt dieser Offline-Modus und so weiter. Also das ist schon alles ganz nett und auch, wenn ich zugeben muss, dass iCAP bei mir noch nicht so richtig in der täglichen Nutzung angekommen ist, also ich ihm auch noch nicht so die Chance gegeben habe, mal eine Weile mein Default-Browser zu sein, ist das schon eine nette Geschichte. Ja, und das ist das, was man eigentlich dazu sagen muss. Also 11.03 ist nicht der derzeitige Entwickler von iCAP, aber es gehört schon so ein bisschen in die Ecke.
Hat man seine Finger mit drin gehabt.
Genau. Ja, also, Leute, habt ihr euch nochmal die iPhone 3.0-Sache irgendwie durch den Kopf gehen lassen?
Durch den Kopf gehen lassen?
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich werde in Zukunft dann auch nicht mehr darüber berichten dürfen, weil ich mir demnächst endlich mal auch so einen D-Verlauber-Count zulegen werde, damit ich damit auch mal umspielen kann, weil das...
Dann habe ich es hier nur noch mit so NDA-Leuten zu tun. Na super. Das heißt, ich bin jetzt der Einzige, der irgendwas erzählen kann und ihr nickt und schüttet mit dem Kopf oder irgendwie sowas. Das wird ja richtig unterhaltsam.
Ich glaube, es kommt ja eh demnächst raus.
Glaubst du wirklich, dass das schon vor dem neuen iPhone rauskommt? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also zusammen.
Ja klar, aber das ist doch im Juni. Achso, gut. Naja, gut. Also ich mein, bis dahin haben wir noch ein paar Sendungen auf der Liste, von daher würde ich das nicht so sehr als bald bezeichnen. Also dass das Ding irgendwie im Juni rauskommt, dass es mehr oder weniger mit der... WWDC zusammenfällt, das scheint, glaube ich, mittlerweile kann man mittlerweile als... Und dann gab es noch die Gerüchte, dass sich Snowlapp hat bis nach August verschiebt. Das würde insofern ins Bild passen. Als dass ja auch das iPhone ein paar Monate herausgekommen ist vor Leopard. Ihr wisst noch, Leopard hat sich verschoben. Und naja, ich denke mir natürlich, dass viele der Änderungen, die jetzt in Snowlapp kommen werden, im Prinzip auch schon im iPhone in irgendeiner Form sich wiederfinden werden. Und dass sie erst mit dem iPhone rauskommen, dann wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen sogar auch die Beta-Version von Snowlapp hat.
Wobei ich das ja eigentlich andersrum machen würde. Weil das OS auf dem Rechner kann man viel einfacher updaten, wenn da Fehler kommen, das im iPhone müssen sie gleich richtig wieder patchen machen, tun und es muss geflasht werden. Es ist halt anfälliger am Ende.
Ja, aber es ist auch weniger. Also es ist ja deutlich weniger.
Das kann sein.
Und es die Plattform jetzt nötiger hat, aus meiner Sicht.
Also nicht weniger im Sinne von Download-Größe, sondern weniger im Sinne von Frameworks, Features und so weiter. Im iPhone ist ja nicht alles drin, was jetzt in Snowlapped drin ist, aber es gibt da halt einfach groß Polynation.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es so der Dreier-Beta zu sagen, dass mittlerweile auch ein paar mehr Sachen gemacht worden sind, als mal zu installieren und Jetzt kam ja auch eine zweite Beta raus. Genau, die zweite Beta ist ja wesentlich stabiler, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, oder? Habe ich mir sagen lassen? So von irgendjemanden? Und soll sogar relativ brauchbar sein?
Ich hab das gelesen, ich hab auch gelesen, dass diese Push-Notification jetzt mit drin ist und ich hab mir da auch noch mal ein bisschen Gedanken zu gemacht und aus einem Artikel entdeckt, der sich auch dazu Gedanken gemacht hat, weil diese Behauptung, dass ein Background-Prozess jetzt zwangsläufig mehr Strom zieht, als der offizielle von Apple designierte Background-Prozess der letzten Endes auch nichts anderes tut als der andere. Das ist so... Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das so ohne weiteres so stehen lassen kann. Aber unabhängig von dieser technischen Bewertung ist es natürlich so, wenn du Push-Notification anbieten möchtest für deinen Dienst oder sagen wir mal, wenn deine Anwendung, die unter Umständen für etwas gemacht ist, was einfach von einem Server lebt, was weiß ich, sowas wie ein Java-Client. Und du möchtest gerne deinen Java-Client so machen, dass er eben eine Nachricht, die dir per Java geschickt wurde, auf das Telefon pusht. Dann musst du deine eigene Backend-Infrastruktur aufrechterhalten, um deine Applikation damit zu versorgen. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt 1000 Kunden hast, 1000 Leute, dann brauchst du eine Infrastruktur, die in der Lage ist, das für 1000 Leute zu machen. Eine Server-Infrastruktur. Genau. Und entsprechend hast du 10.000, musst du das eben auch skalieren.
Und das laufende Kosten sozusagen.
Hättest du einen Background-Prozess, der jetzt ganz normal mit diesem Java-Server kommuniziert, der dann nicht deiner ist, sondern der des Accounts, desjenigen, der das eben nutzt, naja, dann musst du überhaupt keine Infrastruktur stellen, die nicht sowieso schon da ist und die nicht so oder so Teil des Konzeptes ist.
Nein, es ist, also dieser Notification-Dienst ist auf jeden Fall verlagert eher ein Teil der Intelligenz des Programms ins Netz zwangsläufig, weil du bewusst dazu gezwungen, eben wo vorher zum Beispiel ein Pull-Dienst lief, der einfach regelmäßig mal irgendwelche Webseiten abgefragt hat, der muss jetzt in Zukunft dann eben die Nachrichten explizit pushen.
So sieht das aus.
Insofern ist das tatsächlich so ein bisschen was in dieses berühmte Cloud reinschieben.
Ja, und viele Programme sind halt gar nicht dafür ausgelegt, irgendwie nochmal so einen Zwischendienst wie den von Apple zu benutzen. Und die müsste man erstmal umschreiben. Dann werden natürlich die ganzen Developer sagen, nö, machen wir nicht, wir schreiben doch unsere Software nicht für Apple um. Naja, aber es machen wahrscheinlich eher andere, die da wieder Parallelprodukte anbieten und alles wird irgendwie noch schlimmer. Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte gerne beides. Also dass man diesen Dienst nutzen kann, aber dass man ihn nicht nutzen muss für Background-Programme. Das wär schick. Weil für bestimmte Sachen macht das ja schon Sinn.
Für bestimmte Sachen macht das Sinn und bei bestimmten Sachen macht es einfach überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Und die werden das alle benutzen, wie die bekloppen und wahrscheinlich wird Apple noch mal einbrechen und die werden nochmal ordentlich nachschieben. Das wird wahrscheinlich genauso eine Katastrophe wie MobileMe.
Also ich...
Weil die Leute werden natürlich jeden Scheiß darüber abfackeln.
Aber du musst halt für diesen Scheiß auch erstmal Infrastruktur an den Start bringen. Das ist halt nicht so, dass du es mal eben benutzt. Du benutzt es nicht mal eben, sondern du musst ja eigene Infrastruktur bereithalten. In gewisser Hinsicht ist es eine Bevorteilung der Großen. Alle großen Dienste, für die das im Prinzip nur yet another kleiner Server in einem großen Data Center, wo sowieso schon tausend rumstehen, für die ist das halt irgendwie gar kein Thema. Facebook, Twitter und so weiter. Gar kein Ding.
Also gerade Twitter wird sich glaube ich sehr sehr schwer tun. Twitter selbst. Das werden irgendwelche Dienste sein, die das anbieten werden, irgendwelche Clients. Glaube ich nicht. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es allzu schnell von Twitter eine offizielle iPhone-AP geben wird. Sondern das werden die einzelnen Clients machen, wie Tweety und Twitterphone und so. Die werden das dann alle haben.
Das glaube ich überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube exakt das Gegenteil.
Du glaubst, dass Twitter damit sehr schnell kommen wird?
Ich bitte dich, jemand, der einen Twitter-Client schreibt, der hat Experience, das ist vielleicht eine Person, und die hat vielleicht Experience, wie man einen GUI macht und auf dem iPhone oder Objective-C programmiert. Aber der kann dann nicht in derselben Zeit, die ihm zur Verfügung steht, ganz anderes Knowledge auf einem ganz anderen System. Du musst dann erstmal einen Server hosten, und das kostet viel Geld, und das kostet monatlich viel Geld, und das hängt davon ab, wie viele Kunden du hast. Und letzten Endes übernimmst du eine Tätigkeit, die Twitter sehr viel besser übernehmen könnte. Weil für Twitter ist das einfach nur ein anderes Messaging. Da brauchen die irgendwie nicht wirklich, da brauchen die nur andere Software, und da brauchen die noch nicht mal mehr Kapazität für.
Ja, aber ich glaube, also einen Web-Entwickler zu finden, der dir, der einen Cron-Job schreibt, der alle paar Minuten mal abfragt, ob es da irgendwie einen neuen Reply oder sowas für dich gibt.
Da muss es nicht getan. Du musst da irgendwie über Security nachdenken, du musst da über Scalability nachdenken. Das ist richtig Server-Side-Programming. Ja, du hast einen Dienst im Internet. Du bist dann automatisch irgendwie DDoS-anfällig und so weiter.
Wie ihn jeder Blockbetreiber hat und wie... Das ist ja nun nix dramatisch Seltenes oder sowas.
Blockbetreiber finde ich jetzt nicht so dasselbe, weil ein Blockbetreiber, da hast du eine Person, einen Block, eine Infrastruktur pro Person, aber da hast du eine Infrastruktur für jeden deiner Kunden, die dafür Geld bezahlt haben. Und...
Weißt du, du hast eine Infrastruktur für jeden deiner Kunden, die Geld bezahlt haben?
Ja, na klar, wenn ich jetzt ein Programm rausbringe, auf dem iPhone, was halt solche Push-Geschichten in irgendeiner Form benutzt. Und ich bin dann auch noch nicht nur derjenige, der die Applikation anbietet, sondern der dann auch noch diesen Server betreiben muss. Ja, dann stehe ich da im Wort, weil unter Umständen ja die ganze Funktionalität des Programms vollkommen hinten überfällt, wofür du unter Umständen deine 10 Euro genommen hast, wenn dieser Server nicht läuft.
Wenn du 10 Euro nimmst, dann musst du natürlich auch dafür halbwegs gerade stellen. Wenn du 1 Dollar nimmst, dann musst du es unter Umständen nicht. Also ich meine, ich weiß nicht. Also ich halte das...
Das könnte dann schon eher darauf hinauslaufen, dass das Programm dann so Subscriptions noch mitmacht, damit du eben diese Dienstleistung auf Aufrecht erhalten kannst, weil du musst ja mit den Leuten, die dein Programm benutzen, auch eben mit skalieren. Das heißt, du gibst dein Programm für 1 Dollar raus, aber du musst dann für einen Monat Push-Notifications bekommen, dann eben auch nochmal was zahlen.
Also was ich glaube, wie es eigentlich laufen wird, ist, dass wir sind ja dann demnächst in einer sehr lustigen Situation, und zwar nämlich, dass es Push-Notifications auf dem iPhone geben wird. Es wird Push-Notifications auf dem Palm Pre geben, das übrigens relativ ähnlich ist, wie das vom iPhone. Also auch da stellt einem eine Server-Infrastruktur an, die du Nachrichten schicken kannst, und die können als Notifications reingepumpt werden, zusätzlich zu den Background-Prozessen. Das heißt, auf diversen mobilen Plattformen werden wir Notifications haben. Also bei Android ist über XMPP schon ein Notifications-Dienst eingebaut, also über Java quasi. Das einzige, wo das noch fehlt, ist im Web-Browser diese Notifications, bzw. Server-to-Server. Und ich glaube, es wird eher darauf hinauslaufen, dass spätestens mit HTML6, hoffentlich schon mit HTML5, bzw. mit diesen ganzen drum herum liegenden Konglomeraten, endlich mal ein vernünftiger Push-Dienst in HTTP reingeht.
Ja, aber es hat doch beim iPhone jetzt alles nichts zu tun.
Dieser wird dann hoffentlich auch auf dem iPhone gehen, wenn er standardisiert ist und das ein Standard ist, an dem sich alle halten müssen.
Also HTML, HTTP, du wirfst da aber einiges zusammen. Was hat denn das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Ja, unter HTML5 wird ja gerne alles möglich, was man sich anbieten kann, alles Mögliche gepackt, was nicht direkt nur was mit der Sprache zu tun hat, sondern ein ganzes Feature-Set. Da gehört ja auch CSS dazu und so diese ganzen Späße. mit HTML5 meine ich sozusagen den technischen Unterbau der nächsten Web-Generation.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt geraten.
Nein, es ist fällig. Es ist nicht geraten, sondern ich glaube, es ist eine Notwendigkeit, um das Web weiterhin gut wachsen zu lassen.
Ja, aber das hat jetzt erstmal mit dem Push-Dienst von Apple so nichts zu tun und ich meine, die anderen werden natürlich jetzt alles wieder schön kopieren, was Apple da entworfen hat oder vielleicht haben sie sich auch schon sowas Ähnliches überlegt und sind einfach selten gekommen. Basiert auf XMPP plus bei Android gibt es ja auch Hintergrundprozesse und von daher gibt es ja diese Notwendigkeit erstmal nicht unbedingt zu tun. Ich rede nur davon, es ist halt notwendig, wenn du in irgendeiner Form eine Background-Notification machen willst, bist du gezwungen, Infrastruktur für dein Programm hochzuhalten. Und Twitter wäre sehr gut damit bedient, wenn sie den Clients diese Funktionalität in irgendeiner Form bereitstellen. Weil für Twitter selber erinnert sich außer ein bisschen weiteres Software, Server-technisch relativ wenig.
Ich glaube, wir haben im Augenblick andere Probleme. Also sie könnten das sehr gut tun.
Andere Probleme als das iPhone. Bitte dich.
Im Augenblick haben sie ihre Infrastruktur zusammenlaufen halten müssen.
Sie wollen natürlich auch populär bleiben. Und populär bleibt man, wenn man auf dem iPhone richtig funktioniert.
Ihr merkt, der Sommerloch hat wieder richtig zugeschlagen.
Ich glaube, dass es so laufen wird, dass für diese Notification-Dienste, wenn Apple das nicht selber macht, dann findet sich irgendein Dienstleister für ein paar schmale Cent oder ein paar schmale Dollar im Monat die entsprechende Push-Notification anbietet. Das wird schon alles gehen. Was für Notifications braucht man denn überhaupt? Wenn man so einen XMPP-Client oder einen Java-Client schreibt, dann muss man erstmal eine Serverinfrastruktur hochziehen. Wenn man einen Twitter-Client schreibt, muss man auch eine eigene Serverinfrastruktur hochschreiben. Aber bei vielen Diensten...
Du musst immer eine eigene Serverinfrastruktur hochmachen, wenn du Push-Notifications machen willst.
Ja klar, aber was willst du denn überhaupt für Notifications pushen? Meistens hat man ja schon die Serverinfrastruktur, weil es gibt ja überhaupt Nachrichten, die gepusht werden sollen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel...
Guck mal, die ganzen Chat-Tools, dann gibt es ja tausend, es gibt ja nicht nur Java. Da gibt es irgendwie fertige Server. Und die ganzen Server, die sprechen alle nicht mit den App-Notifications.
Das ist kein Spezialfall.
Natürlich, das ist der totale Spezialfall. Ein paar Chat-Applikationen kommen, da wird es dreieinhalb gute Chat-Applikationen geben.
Das geht doch nicht nur über Chat-Applikationen, das geht doch mit allen Servern. Die sind alle nicht darauf ausgewählt.
Deiner. Dein Chat-Server muss das können. Ich mach irgendwie Java, CCC, CDE.
Chat als Beispiel jetzt mal außen vor gelassen.
Das ist primär vital.
Guck mal, wie viele Programme habt ihr auf einem iPhone drauf? Und wie viele davon sind Chat-Applikationen? Ihr habt 50 Applikationen drauf, von denen sind vielleicht 20, die auch Notifications nutzen wollen.
Das ist vollkommen irrelevant, wie viele da jetzt drauf sind. Die Frage ist, wie viele man davon benutzen kann. Ich benutze die jetzt nicht, weil sie eben keine Push-Notification haben. Weil ich halt die ganze Zeit meinen Client laufen lassen müsste. Natürlich will ich da chatten, natürlich will ich da Java drauf haben.
Aber das ist ein Spezialfall und da wird es einen schönen Fall für geben. Aber ich meine, wie viele...
Das ist ein Spezialfall?
Aber bei allen Leuten ein Spezialfall, das ist ja genau das Problem.
Nee, bei den meisten Sachen ist es so, die haben einfach schon ihre eigene Serverinfrastruktur. Du bietest ein iPhone, Facebook hat eine eigene, Quipe hat eine eigene, was haben wir hier drauf?
Aber die sprechen auch alle nicht mit dem Apple-Ding, die müssen das alles umcoden.
Ja, die müssen dann eine zusätzliche Funktionalität einbauen.
Ja, so wie alle. Das ist doch voll das Problem.
Was ist daran voll das Problem? Was werden sie tun?
Weil es teuer ist, das ist doch das, was ich gesagt habe.
Sie schreiben iPhone-Programme, das ist teuer. Und dann ist da so ein kleiner Zusatzdienst, der aber gut oder nicht weh.
Aber ihr iPhone-Programm ist doch nur kompatibel mit demgleichen, was sie auf ihrem Rechner oder auf dem PC schon haben. Das ist alles nicht das Problem. Aber jetzt müssen sie ja beckernend umschreiben.
Nee, das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Max, natürlich stimmt das.
Also ich glaube, Quybe hat bis heute keine offizielle AP. Die, die sie hatten, war ausschließlich fürs iPhone.
Ich weiß nicht, was muss man denn bei Quybe groß messagen?
Und was muss man denn großartig machen, um, wer von uns hat denn diese Notification-Dienst überhaupt genutzt? Geht das vielleicht mit einem einfachen HTTP-Request? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich nehme an, da muss man irgendwas überschreiben.
Keiner von uns hat die genutzt, weil das gibt sie ja noch gar nicht.
Natürlich. Für Entwickler gibt es doch schon Notification-Dienste.
Benutzen tun es Benutzer. Deswegen heißt es Benutzen. Entwickler entwickeln. So, es gibt derzeit einfach noch nichts. Ich würde das in dem Moment benutzen, wo halt etwas erfunden wird, was mit meinem Java-Server zusammenarbeitet. Aber mein Java-Server hat kein Apple-Interface, um die Nachricht auf mein Telefon zu holen.
Aber das ist nicht mein Problem.
Doch, das ist natürlich mein Problem. Wenn du mir eine Java-Nachricht schickst, dann möchte ich gerne, dass es Pling macht auf meinem iPhone.
Also kaufst du dir einen Java-Client, der das machen wird?
Ja, aber wie soll der das tun?
Indem er eine Server-Infrastruktur hat?
Genau, er muss eine Server-Infrastruktur aufbauen und die ist teuer. Und wie funktioniert die? Wieso ist die denn teuer? Wie sicher ist die? Wie identifiziert die sich gegenüber meinem Jabber-Server? Muss ich da mein Passwort abspeichern? Wer ist der Betreiber von diesem Kram? Das sind einfach...
Wenn dir das so unsicher ist, dann lass das halt.
Naja, die Alternative wäre aber, dass ich halt einfach einen Background-Prozess habe auf meinem Telefon, der mit meinem Jabber-Server redet und der unter meiner Kontrolle ist und der auf meinem Telefon läuft. Und das ist doch genau das, was ich meine.
Das ist halt einfach schwierig. Das ist ein Spezialfall.
Das ist der Fall, weil es geht ja hier vor allem...
Es geht nicht um Chat-Applikation.
Natürlich geht es hier um Chat-Applikation.
Also das, was Apple gezeigt hat, zu einem Bruchteil waren das nur Chat-Applikation.
Aber das gilt doch für die anderen auch. Ist doch egal, ob es Chat ist oder nicht.
Also was hat denn Apple da noch gezeigt, außer Chat-Applikation?
Zum Beispiel hatten sie von diesem Sportdienst, dass man informiert wird, wenn wie ein Spiel ausgegangen ist. Ist keine Chat-Applikation.
Das stimmt.
Also kommt, wir haben hier... Was habe ich hier für Programme drauf, die Notifications brauchen könnten? Mail könnten Notifications brauchen. Ich habe einen RSS-Reader, der könnte Notifications gebrauchen. Ich habe einen Twitter Client, der könnte Notifications gebrauchen. Wetter könnte manetwegen, wir regelmäßig mal durchschicken, wie das Wetter jetzt da unter ist.
Du sagst doch, dein Klein, den du hast. Zum Beispiel was hast du gesagt? RSS-Reader, richtig? Den findest du irgendwie toll. So, wenn Apple jetzt Background-Applikation erlauben würde, dann könntest du genau den weiter benutzen. Du wirst im Hintergrund laufen und der kriegt irgendwie alles mit und könnte sein eigenes Icon vorne updateen, weil er halt noch läuft. Das geht aber nicht. Also muss genau dieser RSS-Client jetzt ein Backend haben, wo sie über Apple halt dir die Notification schicken. Dazu muss er sein Backend umschreiben. Wenn er das aber nicht macht, kannst du dieses Tool nicht mehr so benutzen, wie du gerne möchtest.
Dann würde ich ein anderes nutzen.
Dann wirst du ein anderes nutzen. Das muss aber jemand machen. Das ist halt alles blöd, weil eigentlich bräuchte man nur, also Apple bräuchte eigentlich nur ein Hähnchen setzen und Background-Applikation erlauben und für alle anderen wäre alles super.
Und so werden halt die bevorteilt, die schon Infrastruktur haben.
Aber, also ich meine, wir können doch, du kannst doch auf deinem iPhone, also ich kann auf meinem iPhone Background-Prozesse nutzen, wenn ich's will. Jeder kann Jailbreak machen, kann man Background-Prozesse nutzen.
Ja, Jailbreak modifiziert mein Gerät und ändert unter Umständen die Sicherheit des Gerätes.
Ich hab auch keinen Jailbreak, hab ich entfernt.
Ja, okay, also so wichtig scheint euch Hintergrund-Prozesse nicht zu sein, oder?
Doch, aber ich will es in ordentlich haben.
Ja, ich auch und in sicher.
Und viele andere auch.
Also ich hab kein großes Interesse an einem Gerät, was ich nur dann betreiben kann, wenn ich es irgendwie breche. Also das ist mir dann nicht wert. Also entweder hat es in seiner Standard-Ausrüstung alles, was ich haben will, oder das macht es zumindest so, wie ich es haben möchte.
Ja, aber die Problematik ist doch, dass und das ist doch wirklich nur mal ein Fakt, wenn jeder, der mein Android-Telefon benutzt hat oder jeder, der mein Symbian-Telefon benutzt hat, sobald man Hintergrundprozesse laufen lässt, wird der Akku schneller leer und das Gelekt wird langsamer.
Ja, das kann ich dann aber in Kauf nehmen. Das ist ja das Ding, das nehme ich ja unter Umständen auch in Kauf. Bloß Apple möchte nicht das global in Kauf nehmen. Das kann ich ja auch nachvollziehen. Es ist nachvollziehbar, dass sie das nicht wollen. Ich sage nur, das Modell, was sie jetzt ausrollen, benachteiligt kleine Entwickler, macht es schwierig für Dienste, wo du nicht mal eben so eine Infrastruktur überhaupt dazwischen packen kannst. Zum Beispiel ich möchte eine sichere Kommunikation mit meinem Java-Server haben. Da kann man nicht mal eben irgendeine Infrastruktur dazwischen packen, weil das würde bedeuten, dass meine Nachrichten auf einem anderen Server landen als auf meinem. Aber deswegen habe ich ja meinen, damit es meiner ist. Bei E-Mail und bei ähnlichen Diensten das gleiche. Wenn man halt eh schon bei Facebook ist, entfällt natürlich dieses Problem, weil man hat sowieso seine Nachrichten schon auf einem ganz anderen Dienst. Und für die ist es halt auch einfach. Die freuen sich, die großen Sportdienste freuen sich. Alle freuen sich. Ich sage nicht, dass die Leute nicht glücklich sind damit. Also es wird ein Großteil der Entwickler-Community vom iPhone. Für die ist das wirklich toll. Aber es ist halt noch nicht alles. Aber wir müssen das jetzt nicht weiter vertiefen. Du kannst ja lieber mal erzählen, was du für ein Feedback bekommen hast auf deinen Screencast.
Ach stimmt. Genau. Wie ja wahrscheinlich einige von euch mitbekommen habt, habe ich das erste Mal einen Screencast ausprobiert. Das war mehr so aus der Laune heraus. Auch jetzt mache ich meinen Screencast, weil eigentlich könnte man mal ganz gut erklären, wie das dann funktioniert. Das man Eventbox und Dropbox usw. synchronisiert. Und das haben wir gemacht mit der Software Screenflow. Du hast die sogar noch, Tim hat die dann sich in die Unkosten hineingestürzt, kopfüber und hat Screenflow gekauft für uns. Und damit habe ich dann so ein, wie heißt jetzt das Wort, Screencast aufgenommen? Jetzt hatte ich das Wort kurz vergessen.
Ja, du hast ein Screencast aufgenommen.
Ich habe ein Screencast aufgenommen. Ganz alleine von meinem Rechner. Und das hat hervorragend funktioniert. Also diese Software Screenflow ist echt schick. Also das ist so eine Aufnahmesoftware, gibt es ja einige von. Es gibt zum Beispiel, wofür ich sogar noch eine Seriennummer rumfliegen hatte. Also was ich irgendwann mal gekauft hatte, das ist dieser Snaps Pro von Ambrosia Software. Es gibt da einige Programme. Was das Schicke an Screenflow ist, das zeichnet das auf und man kann eine Menge noch im Nachhinein bearbeiten. Also wenn man zum Beispiel feststellt, aha, dieses Fenster war ein bisschen zu klein, dann kann man sagen, dann blase ich das ein bisschen auf. Und dann wird das größer dargestellt. Das habe ich dann zum Beispiel genutzt, um die Terminent Fenster ein bisschen größer darzustellen. Kann das nutzen, um visuelle Effekte im Nachhinein einzubauen. Das ist echt eine ganz großartige Sache. Während dieses Screencast hatte ich ja das Problem, dass ich auf zwei Rechner zugreifen musste, weil es ging darum, dass Daten zwischen zwei Rechnern abgeglichen werden. Die hatte ich dann per VNC verbunden, was ja sicherlich die meisten kennen werden. VNC kann man auf Mac einschalten in den Systemeinstellungen bei Sharing, da heißt das glaube ich entfernte Bildschirmsteuerung. Screensharing. Als Client habe ich benutzt Jolly's Fast VNC heißt der. Das ist einer der, ich würde sagen, der beste VNC Client auf dem Mac überhaupt.
Chicken VNC oder wie hieß das früher?
Chicken VNC, Chicken of the VNC war, da habe ich jahrelang gebraucht um den Witz zu verstehen. Das ist... Es gibt eine Thunfischsorte in Amerika, die heißt Chicken of the Sea. Also Hühnchen, also weil das so wenig... Chicken of the VNC.
Ich glaube, ein Fisch, der so schmeckt wie Hühn. Das ist das, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, das war irgendwie von den Kalorien her und ist so leicht und so fettarm und weiß ja toll was. Und darum hatten die auch als Eiken so ein Hühnchen, was aus so einer Dose rausguckte. Und das war früher so der VNC Client, der war aber immer unglaublich langsam. Jollies Fast VNC heißt so, weil er ist ziemlich schnell. Man kann eine SSH-Verbindung direkt aufmachen in Jollies Fast VNC. Auch mit Public Key und allem. Also das heißt, ich kann mich mit meinem Server zuhause verbinden, ohne extra vorher bei irgendein anderes Programm SSH-Tunnel öffnen zu müssen. Und er braucht nicht viel Prozessorlast im Hintergrund. Und geschrieben hat er das Programm ursprünglich mal, weil er ein, wie ich finde, komplett unnützes, aber doch ziemlich cleveres Programm geschrieben hat. Es hieß Screen Recycler und zwar basierte das auf der Idee, dass man ja manchmal, hat man ja noch irgendwie einen alten Rechner rumstehen, zum Beispiel ein Laptop und da ist dann das Display eingebaut. Man könnte dieses Display ja als zweites Display für den eigentlichen Hauptrechner nutzen. Und darum hat man da eine Software geschrieben, mit der man den eingebauten, also mit der man einen zweiten Bildschirm simulieren kann an seinem Haupt-Mac.
Übers Netz, ohne dass man halt da...
Übers Netz. Und hat dann festgestellt, hat das über VNC gemacht und weil das überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, weil die alle viel zu langsam waren auf dem Mac, hat er dann diesen Jollies, also seinen eigenen VNC-Client geschrieben. Und, ja, das ist... Der hat sich dann sehr gefreut. Der hat sich dann irgendwie per Twitter gemeldet, dass er, wie toll er es findet, dass ich seinen Client benutze und das ist ein großartiges Programm. Also ich benutze das seit Jahren eigentlich. Und wie...
Ist es denn wirklich so sehr viel schneller als jetzt zum Beispiel Remote Desktop oder der eingebaute Screensharing Client?
Der eingebaute Screensharing Client ist... Ja, ist deutlich schneller. Also der braucht irgendwann... Also dieses Screensharing Client, abgesehen davon, dass es eben solche Features wie SSH nicht hat, braucht er irgendwann zwischendurch mal 60 Prozent Prozessorlast. Keine Ahnung warum, obwohl...
Über das VNC-Protokoll?
Über das VNC-Protokoll. Und das hat der einfach nicht. Das ist ein Programm, das ist darauf, der steckt viel Zeit rein, nur um diesen VNC-Dienst zu optimieren. Hat sogar so schöne Sachen drinne, wie jetzt, das ist ganz schick, wenn man so ein kleines Display hat.
Also weißt du denn, warum der jetzt so viel schneller ist?
Ich nehme an, einfach sauberer implementiert, besser die Zeit gestoppt, besser reingesetzt.
Du musst immer dein Mikrofon mal ein bisschen...
Bin ich zu nah dran?
Du bist ein bisschen zu pumpend.
Gut.
So, jetzt hat sie es ausgepumpt.
Jetzt hat sie es ausgepumpt.
Und es hat sich ausgemerkt, wo ich überhaupt war. Achso, ja, in einer der letzten Versionen hat er ein relativ schönes Feature eingebaut. Man hat ja immer das Problem, oder nicht immer, aber man hat ein kleines Display und möchte darauf ein großes VNC-Display darstellen. Und die übliche Variante dafür ist natürlich einfach, das Display dann zu verkleinern. Also, dass man in Fullscreen-Modus geht und dann siehst du eben, dass den Inhalt des großen Displays ein bisschen verkleinert. Und da hat er jetzt eine Art Lupenfunktion eingebaut. Also, dass du den Rand immer noch verkleinert siehst. So ein bisschen perspektivisch. Aber innen drin einen größeren Bereich hast, auf dem du die volle Größe hast. Das ist ziemlich großartig. Also, der gibt sich da echt Mühe. Und ist ein kleines Freeware-Programm. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn er eines Tages dafür auch ein bisschen Geld haben will. Weil, ist ein wirklich sehr guter Klein. Ich würde ihn kaufen.
Du würdest ihn kaufen?
Ich würde ihn nutzen jeden Tag.
Ich dachte ja, das wäre Kaufsoftware für euch.
Nein, also dieses Screen Recycler dazu, diese Monitor-Software, die kostet Geld.
Die kostet fast, aber Jolly's Fast Forward C ist...
Aber Jolly's Fast Forward C kostet nichts.
Okay, das Anfallprodukt sozusagen.
Genau.
Fein. Ja, Screencast, machst du noch mal welche?
Sobald ich mal wieder ein Thema habe, ja. Also es ist so ein bisschen, vielleicht habt ihr die ganzen Ideen. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen themenabhängig, weil es sollte ja ein Thema sein, was jetzt nicht so unglaublich komplex ist.
Man kann nicht einfach so einen Screencast machen, auch wenn man kein Thema hat. Du kannst ja einfach mal zwei Stunden lang dich beim Surfen einfach so mit allen...
Ich meine, wir machen auch einen Podcast ohne Thema. Insofern sollte auch ein Screencast ohne Thema jetzt nicht so dramatisch sein, aber...
Der Podcast ohne Thema, ja. Was ist denn denn das nächste Nichts-Thema in unserem Podcast-Thema? Also, hier wurde ja auch einiges wieder über die Webseite hineingeworfen. Da wollen wir doch mal durchaus drauf eingehen, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt hier hab grad ein paar Kommentare freigeschaltet. 58 Kommentare macht uns fertig!
Du hast gerade 58 Kommentare freigeschaltet?
Insgesamt sind jetzt hier 58 Antworten gekommen auf unser Blog. Unter anderem wurde bemängelt, dass wir noch nicht auf die Sommerzeit umgestellt haben. Hast du das schon behoben?
Ne, hab ich jetzt noch nicht behoben, weil ich das Passwort gerade nicht hier habe für den entsprechenden Server. Das kannst du umstellen, hin zu dem Admin-Interface.
Das macht doch der Rechner automatisch.
Tja, keine Ahnung. Warum geht es denn nicht auf dem Blog?
Das muss man in den Blog-Einstellungen einmal, zweimal im Jahr muss man das selber von Hand machen. Das kannst du auch mit deiner Hand machen.
Man muss der Blog-Software sagen, dass Sommerzeit ist.
Aber das sagt ihm doch der Server.
Das sollte ihm eigentlich der Server sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Server ihm das nicht vernünftig sagt, aber der Server sagt es ihm nicht vernünftig.
Abgesehen davon, Sommerzeit gehört abgeschafft, finde ich. Also wenn man will, dass die Bars länger offen haben, dann soll man einfach die Bars länger öffnen. Oder früher, je nachdem, was man gerade so braucht. Sommerzeit kostet viele Menschen das Leben.
Sommerzeit, das ist jetzt mal eine gewagte Theorie.
Nee, das ist keine gewagte Theorie, das ist alles schon belegt. Also es gibt wirklich in allgemeinen Unfall-Statistiken die Umstellung von Sommer- auf Winterzeit und Winter- auf Sommerzeit ablesen.
Meinst du, sie sitzen im Auto und sagen, hä, was ist mit dem Crash?
Nee, weil die Leute einfach aus ihrem Biorhythmus rausgebracht werden dadurch.
Ist nicht die Sommerzeit sowieso von den Nazis eingeführt worden? Das erste Mal?
Weltweit, meinst du?
Die Sommerzeit verdanken wir den Italienern.
Wie, den Italienern?
Damit man den Strandbars länger Umsatz machen kann.
Na ja, aber ich hab mal gehört, dass das eigentliche wirtschaftliche, nach dem Motto, dann ist es länger hell, dann brauchen wir in kriegswichtigen Zeiten. Aber ich lehne mich jetzt gerade extrem weit aus dem Fenster, ohne wirklich den blassesten Schimmer zu haben.
Lass uns nicht über Nazis diskutieren. Es war der Italiener.
Vielleicht italienische Nazis?
Da will ich jetzt auch überhaupt nicht drauf eingehen. Nee, es sind halt diese albernen Argumente, dass irgendwie auf einmal die Welt besser wäre, weil man irgendwie die Zeit verschiebt. Tatsache ist, dass wir alle permanent zweimal im Jahr darunter leiden und niemand so richtig versteht, warum das eigentlich sein muss. Lockfiles gehen in den Arsch. Systeme, die einfach von Zeit abhängen müssen, eine bekloppte Umrechnung machen, die noch nicht mal weltweit synchron ist und auch gar nicht einheitlich ist. Das ist einfach alles Quatsch.
Was haben wir die Sommerzeit zwischendurch mehrfach abgeschafft und wieder eingeführt und abgeschafft und findet dann sowieso in anderen Ländern zu einer ganz anderen Zeit statt?
Daylight-Saving-Time, sage ich nur. Da wird überhaupt niemand gesaved. Das ist einfach alles großer Humbug. Aber das war ehrlich gesagt nichts, was in den Kommentaren aufgetaucht ist.
Doch, natürlich in den Kommentaren tauchte auf, dass wir keine Sommerzeit haben.
Ja, aber nicht, dass wir in dieser Sommerzeit reden müssen. Themenvorschlag hieße hier gleich, der erste sollte Apple Sun übernehmen oder zumindest alle ZFS-Entwickler. Kann Mac OS X etwas von Solaris lernen? Kennst du Solaris denn jetzt?
Na nee, nicht so wirklich. Nee, gar nicht eigentlich.
Unglaublich stabil durchzulaufen, oder? Solaris gilt doch als monsterstabil, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Ja, aber es wird auch oft Slow-Laris genannt.
Kennst du, es könnte von Solaris lernen, ein bisschen langsamer zu sein?
Bestimmt.
Aber auch nur, weil es sich da so gut ergibt, oder?
Wobei auch viele sagen, es ist wirklich Rock'n'Roll-Stable, aber da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch viele, die sagen, es ist offen wie ein Scheuntor, sicherheitsmäßig. Ich hab da keine Ahnung.
Ich habe auch keine konkreten Erfahrungen. Ich möchte jetzt auch gar keine Mutmaßung darüber machen, ob es jetzt für alle mehr oder weniger stabil ist. Ich glaube, dass es im Großen und Ganzen vor allem durch Universalität im Serverbereich glänzt. Also was ich häufiger höre, ist, dass dieses Trail-Konzept von...
Die Zonen.
Die Zonen von Solaris doch eine ganz tolle Erfindung sein sollen, weil man da irgendwie alles Mögliche konfigurieren kann und eben auch keine Einschränkungen hat. Du weißt, wovon wir reden, Max?
Nee, ich hab kein Bussenschimmer, ich hätte als nächstes gefragt. Was sind Zonen?
Aber in Jail sagt dir was.
Also ich kenne eine CH-Rooted-Umgebung.
Geht's?
Geht das schon in die Richtung?
Es geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung. Generell, wenn man auf jedem Server oder auf jedem Computer hat man immer diesen Bedarf einer Sandbox. Du willst halt immer irgendwie etwas in einen Sandkasten stecken, wo es eben... Jaja, einen Sandkasten. Du möchtest halt sozusagen verhindern, dass irgendetwas was Schlimmes anstellt und du möchtest halt in gewisser Hinsicht auch so eine Virtualisierung haben. Das heißt, du möchtest, dass dein System sich verhält wie mehrere Computer gleichzeitig. Und, das weiß ich, du installierst einen WordPress in einem von diesen virtuellen Computern und ein was weiß ich Server, was anderem. Und wenn halt einer irgendwie aufgemacht wird, dann bewegt sich halt der Einbrecher nur Entschuldigung. bewegt er sich halt nur in diesem einen Jail eben so und kommt da nicht raus. Zumindest nicht ohne weiteres. Und die Security des einen Systems betrifft halt nicht automatisch die Security des anderen.
Also dieses schöne, was man auch mit also Virtualisierung eigentlich quasi.
Ja, aber Virtualisierung bezieht sich halt im Wesentlichen auf die Prozessoren, wo du halt wirklich einen Computer virtualisierst, aber die Zonen und Jails sind eigentlich mehr, dass nur das Betriebssystem virtualisiert wird. Dass du scheinbar mehrere Betriebssysteminstanzen läufst, obwohl es eigentlich nur eine ist.
Und kann ich dadurch dann auch besser Arbeitsspeicher und Prozessorleistung und sowas verteilen oder?
Das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Frage. Vor allem ist es so ein Security- und administrativer Fragestellung. Jails, zum Beispiel bei FreeBSD, haben heute noch so diverse Einschränkungen, dass zum Beispiel kein Local Host, ganz kein IPv6 machen und so. Das wird sich halt irgendwann nochmal ändern. Aber die Zonen bei Solaris haben halt diese Einschränkungen in der Form, soweit ich das gehört habe, nicht. Aber das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht die Frage. Die Frage war ja, sollte Apple Sun übernehmen?
Warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Also das werden sie auf gar keinen Fall machen.
So richtig Apples Ding, so Business Zeug irgendwie, das würde, weiß nicht.
Business Zeug ist schon Apples Ding, aber es...
Nee, aber so richtig Business Kunden, also so Unis und große, dicke Firmen, die voll viel Rechenpower, oder nee, Rechenpower, EU-Power brauchen.
Aber Apple kauft generell nicht so richtig große Firmen auf, oder? Die so ein komplexes Produktportfolio haben.
Nee, die erfinden lieber was Neues und bauen das selber auf und entwickeln den Markt von alleine.
Und Sun ist ja nun auch eher eine Firma auf der Suche nach einem Geschäftsmodell, der mich nicht alles täuscht.
Na ja, Sun hat schon ein Geschäftsmodell. Sun macht halt Enterprise.
Genau, die verkauft diese tollen Server. Aber so richtig.
Nicht nur die tollen Server, die haben auch Java zum Beispiel erfunden, du wirst dich erinnern, das durchaus weite Verbreitung hat.
Java, ja, ich erinnere mich.
Sie sind da...
Verkaufen sie das auch mittlerweile?
Sie sind in gewisser Hinsicht da auch fett im Geschäft. Java ist ja jetzt weitgehend unter freien Lizenzen verfügbar. Bloß verkaufen tun sie natürlich trotzdem noch eine ganze Menge. Sehr viel, was da dranhängt. Dienstleistungen, Pipapo, sie werden auch noch Produkte haben, für die Geld genommen werden, die auch auf Java basieren. Also Java ist mittlerweile eine Enabling-Infrastructure oder eine Enabling-Technology. Sicherlich sind die Rechte an Java haben auch einen gewissen Wert.
Na, ohne Frage.
Ja, das ist durchaus auch etwas, woraus man noch Geld machen kann, wenn man halt versteht, wie. Inwieweit das jetzt Sun selber gelingt, darüber kann man, glaube ich, geteilter Meinung sein. So richtig gut geht es Sun auf jeden Fall nicht. Also der Aktienkurs hat auch schon mal bessere Zeiten gesehen. Auch wenn sie weitgehend mit ihren Grundvisionen so falsch nicht ganz gerechnet gelegen haben. Ich erinnere nur an dieses The Network is the Computer-Ding, wo sie am Anfang auch mit...
Das war dieses vor zehn Jahren, als sie so gesagt haben, wir bauen kleine Mini-Boxen, die gar nichts können und nur Java können. Und man kann dann Bildschirm anschließen in Tastatur und damit ein Netzwerkkabel.
Genau. Und das war auch eine nachvollziehbare Vision. Im Prinzip ist das der alte Unix-Traum. Der Unix-Traum sagt, du hast halt dicke Server und du benutzt das dann eben über Terminals.
Also eigentlich ist das, was heute unter dem schönen Namen Cloud-Computing ein bisschen verbrämt wird, auf eine neue Art.
Aber ein Zacken radikaler.
Ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte, würde ich sagen. Aber grundsätzlich war es halt einfach die Idee von Light-Wide-Terminals. Die sich in gewissen, also in manchen Bereichen macht das ja auch durchaus Sinn. Früher, wenn du Unix in der Firma hattest, dann hattest du halt deinen dicken Unix-Rechner irgendwo in der EDV-Zentrale stehen und dann hast du überall V24-Kabel gelegt und dann hattest du da irgendwie 10-20 Terminals dran. Und da lief dann halt irgendwie die Kassen-Software. Und tatsächlich ist es ja auch so, selbst wo heute überall Windows steht, hast du dann häufig Programme, die dann eben auf die zentrale Datenbank zugreifen. Und du hast dann eigentlich auch nur deine Eingabemasken und du replizierst eine ganze Menge der Funktionalität wiederum auf diesen Clients, die selber alle sehr viel Geld kosten. Und am Ende landet es sowieso zentral auf dem Server. Dann, so war ja dann die Aussage von Sun, dann könnte man es doch halt auch gleich auf dem Server laufen lassen und du exportierst eigentlich nur noch das User-Interface. Diese Version ist ja auch so nichts Neues, sondern das hat sich dann mit HTML ja auch nochmal so gebracht.
Mit einem ganz simplen X-Server muss man ja auch mal sagen. Also Unix ist ja, kann ich ja auch den X-Server, kann ich ja auch auf ein komplett anderes Display rausschießen.
Es gibt alle möglichen Level und deswegen gibt es auch keine einfache Art Antwort. Also vom HTML-Formular, wo du ja im Prinzip auch direkt auf dem Server arbeitest.
Web-Apps gehen ja auch wieder in die Richtung eigentlich.
Genau, trotzdem hast du dann aber auch immer wieder den Bedarf, du willst dann doch ein komplexes User-Interface haben, du willst es lokal einfach machen, du willst Offline-Storage haben. Das ist ja das, was wir jetzt auch gerade im Webbereich sehen. Und ich war immer mehr JavaScript, immer mehr Frameworks, die dann in deinem Web-Browser laufen, die Möglichkeit offline zu sein, weil man eben auch nicht unbedingt immer online ist. Das Internet ist halt nicht unbedingt immer da, gerade im mobilen Bereich und so weiter. Von daher ist das auch ein Moving Target. Und am Ende hat sich in den letzten zehn Jahren tatsächlich einfach der Desktop gehalten. Der Desktop ist das erfolgreichste System der letzten zehn Jahre gewesen mit Windows und ein Stück weit eben auch wieder mit dem Mac. Die Leute wollen dann doch in der Masse, im Konsumerbereich zumindest, wollen sie halt Full Featured-Computer haben. Und der Trend zu leichtgewichtigen Geräten ist halt jetzt wieder mal was Neues. Mit diesen Netbooks haben wir das so ein bisschen, dass man sagt, ich verzichte auf Komplexität und gehe mehr darauf, dass ich eigentlich nur noch Serverdienste mache. Ich benutze das Web, ich hab meine Mail zentral und mehr benutze ich auch nicht. Wie auch immer. Die eigentliche Frage war ja, sollte Apple Sun übernehmen? Das kann man glaube ich ganz einfach mit Nein beantworten, denn das Business-Modell, der Kundenkreis, die Produkte von Sun sind für Apple vollkommen uninteressant. Also das ist einfach nichts, wo Apple was von hätte. Abgesehen davon müssten sie sich da mit so Restrukturierungsmaßnahmen beschäftigen und irgendeinem Quatsch und im Prinzip müssten sie auch das Business-Modell von Sun retten. Das überlassen sie glaube ich dann schon lieber Sun selber, weil Interesse hat Apple eigentlich derzeit nur an verschiedenen Technologien, die Sun produziert und die nutzen sie ja auch. Bei ZFS ist das jetzt glaube ich so die dritte Sache oder so. Was noch? Na Java ist ein fester...
Java ist doch eigentlich wieder...
Java ist ein ziemlicher Stiefkind...
.spielt nicht mehr die große Rolle, aber ist immerhin noch dabei.
da gab es nochmal eine Java-Bridge für den Xcode auch irgendwie, ist alles wieder entfernt worden.
Ja, das haben sie aufgegeben. Sie waren ja mal eine Weile der Meinung, dass Java für sie eine strategische Entwicklungsgeschichte sein kann. Das stammt ja noch aus den Anfangs von Mac OS X, wo eben noch gar nicht so klar war, dass sie mit ihrem Coco wirklich wieder so nach vorne schießen.
Nein, man muss ja auch mal sagen, Apple hat ja damals auch Next aufgekauft und Next hat ja eine sehr wichtige Software, WebObjects, die vielleicht...
Die auch nach Java umgestellt, ne?...
die auch auf Java portiert worden ist und dann komplett Java war. Also früher brauchte man ja Next-Maschinen, um WebObjects überhaupt starten zu können. Und irgendwann haben sie ja daraus dann eine Java-Version gemacht, die auf so ziemlich allem läuft. Und WebObjects ist ja auch durchaus bei Firmen wie... Ich weiß nicht, ob heute noch, aber damals Amazon hat das, glaube ich, eingesetzt.
Genau, aber jetzt aber zwei Sachen nicht verwechseln. Das eine ist Mac OS X und das andere sind sonstige Produkte. WebObjects ist etwas für den Server. Und im Servermarkt hat Java gewonnen. So, das kann man soweit sagen. Also zumindest vorerst. Im Enterprise-Bereich besonders, aber auch bei vielen komplexen Web-Anwendungen. Da willst du ganz einfach mit Java viel besser diesen ganzen Mumpel zusammen integrieren. Aber jetzt in Mac OS X, und was für Apple wirklich auch jetzt das relevante Business ist, weil diese Serverseite ist für Apple kein relevantes Business, da spielen Sun-Technologien halt einfach nur hier und da eine Rolle. Ich meine, es gibt ein paar ganz wichtige. ZFS haben wir schon hier mehrfach ausführlich dargelegt. Denke ich mal, ist ganz strategisch sehr wichtig. Aber sie haben ja jetzt auch mit Leopard den Words Are Fading Me, wie heißt noch gleich, den Kernel Trace.
Genau, dieses Detrace.
Genau, die Detrace-Funktionalität, das kommt halt von Solaris. Das haben sie halt eingebaut und das ist etwas, womit man einfach sehr effektiv Debugging betreiben kann auf Systemlevel.
Ist das Grün dafür auf aktuell, heißt jetzt Instruments oder X-Ray?
X-Ray sollte es mal heißen.
Dann haben sie es nach Instruments umgedankt.
Jetzt nennen sie das so wie Instruments. Genau, jetzt hast du da so deine Instrumententafel, mit dem du eben das Ganze machen kannst. Also da sieht man auch, dass Apple in der Lage ist, sich schweres Zeug zu legen, wenn so eine Technologie für sie relevant ist, das dann eben auch voll zu integrieren. Also Detrace, Java und ZFS. Aber deswegen müssen sie es dann nicht kaufen. Das eigentliche Gerücht, was ja derzeit durch die Gazetten geht, ist ja...
Vor allem muss man ja auch schon ZFS, deswegen muss man da nichts kaufen, weil es ja frei ist, also...
Naja, aber man will unter Umständen die Weiterentwicklung und solche Einrichtungen bekommen.
Aber da werden die schon entsprechende Deals haben und eine von den Apple-Programmierern, diese Noel de la Fane, oder wie sie heißt, arbeitet ja schon bei Apple, also so ist ja nicht.
Ja, im Zweifelsfall... Also sollte jetzt Sun wirklich komplett vom Planeten verschwinden, was nicht passieren wird, dann müssen die Programmierer am nächsten Tag auch wieder irgendwo arbeiten.
Ich glaube, die ZFS-Programmierer haben kein Problem, irgendwie einen Arbeitgeber zu finden.
Das glaube ich auch nicht. Also wenn irgendjemand wirklich keine Sorgen hat, dann sind es irgendwie ganze ZFS-Leute. So, aber wer will denn jetzt eigentlich Sun kaufen?
IBM wollte und hat sich aber ganz schnell wieder zurückgezogen, wobei ich mal überlegt habe, wenn als riesengroße Firma würde ich natürlich auch immer erstmal so tun, als wenn ich Interesse hätte. Erstens drückt es den Preis hoch, falls meine Konkurrenten den Laden kaufen wollen. Dann kann ich es denen halt schon ein bisschen teurer machen. Alleine dadurch, dass ich Interesse zeige. Zweitens, wenn ich nicht will, dass meine Konkurrenz den Laden so schnell kauft, dann zeige ich halt auch Interesse, weil das die ganze Sache halt in die Länge zieht und für die dauert es immer länger, bis sie den Laden kriegen. Also die spielen ja auch ihre Spielchen.
Ich glaube aber ehrlich gesagt, dass IBM Sun kaufen will. Naja klar, weil das ist ihr Business. IBM ist Enterprise.
Ja, aber es muss natürlich auch, darf ja nicht zu teuer sein.
Ach, ja, natürlich darf es nicht zu teuer sein. Die Frage ist ja für sie einfach, können sie mit Sun im Portfolio etwas besser tun, als sie es derzeit tun können?
Und, können sie?
Naja, ich stecke mich jetzt in den Köpfen von IBM, aber wenn ich mir halt anschaue, was für IBM der Markt ist, dann ist das halt erstmal Enterprise, denn da gibt es zwischen IBM und Sun einfach mal großflächige Überschneidung. Eine Welt ohne Sun ist ein Konkurrent weniger. Andererseits ist zum Beispiel Java für IBM ein echt großes Thema. Die haben also sehr viel investiert in Java-Technologie, auch in Linux, nicht so sehr jetzt in Solaris, auch nicht in BSD, an der Stelle passen sie halt nicht so gut zusammen, aber eben sehr wohl in Java. Das kann durchaus ein Punkt sein. Wenn jetzt IBM Sun kauft, dann ist Java eine IBM-Technologie. Und das heißt, IBM leitet den Weg, wohin es geht mit Java im Enterprise-Business. Und ich glaube, das ist so eine Art Einfluss, den sie schon gerne hätten. IBM ist schon einfach immer gerne mal der Chef. Und von daher würde es, glaube ich, ganz gut passen.
Aber so als Endanwender hört man von IBM ja eigentlich nichts mehr, oder?
Nö, nicht so viel. Aber vielleicht ist der Grund ja auch ZFS.
Kann auch sein, aber dazu muss man Sun nicht kaufen, glaube ich.
Naja, man muss aber vielleicht Sun kaufen, um Sun dazu bringen, ZFS oder GPL zu releasen. Und nur dann kannst du es nämlich in Linux einbauen. IBM setzt sehr breitflächig auf Linux. Und bei Linux zeichnet es sich nicht ab, dass dem nicht so was kommt wie ZFS.
Also, wenn ich eine große Firma wäre, ich würde nicht ZFS kaufen, damit ich den Linux-Leuten vor die Füße werfe. Die haben so viele 1000 Filesystems. Das geht doch da völlig unter. Die bekloppen sich doch so schon gegenseitig.
Wenn IBM das selber portiert, dann kann denen das vollkommen schnurzegal sein. Dann haben sie einfach diese Technologie.
Also ich glaube, da wäre Apple echt ein besserer Käufer für ZFS, weil die benutzen es wenigstens denn dediziert.
Und bei Linux ist es so eins von vielen. Nein, Apple muss es nicht kaufen, weil es ist BSD lizenziert.
Dann muss man auch nichts daran ändern. Die bei Linux, die wollen das eh nicht.
IBM will es vielleicht. Die bei Linux, ich meine, da gibt es mehrere. Da gibt es halt die Szene und dann gibt es die Firmen. Und ich glaube, dass ZFS schon ein guter Grund sein kann, Sun-Hardware zu kaufen und nicht IBM-Server. Ich meine, was würdest du machen, wenn du eine große Firma wärst und du musstest jetzt mal irgendwie deine Datenbestände irgendwie sichern? Was würdest du kaufen? Du würdest losrennen und du würdest ZFS kaufen. Und dann gehst du zu IBM und sagst, guten Tag, ich hätte gerne mal einmal eure Linux-Server mit ZFS. Und dann sagen die, ja, wissen sie, also man muss das ja nicht so genau nehmen. Wenn du ein Enterprise bist, dann fragst du nicht nach Linux, sondern dann gehst du zu den drei großen Buchstaben oder zu den anderen drei großen Buchstaben. Und dann fragst du halt einfach, wie viel von den 30 Buzzwords, die du auf der letzten Cebit von deinem Manager diktiert bekommen hast, hier abhaken kannst. Und dann steht da halt irgendwo das Buzzword drauf, muss Daten sicher speichern können. Blah. Naja, du weißt schon. Also halt, wenn da nicht sogar ZFS steht. Das kann ja durchaus sein. So, was weiß ich? Wir müssen unsere Daten mit Checksummen sichern. Punkt. Und wir müssen irgendwie Poolmanagement haben, und das muss irgendwie alles funktionieren. Was haben Sie denn da im Angebot? Ja, dann haben wir einfach mal gar nichts.
Die haben das ja auch alles, kostet halt nur.
Gut, aber ich denke, dass auch Suns Java-Welt da eine große Rolle spielt. Und dass halt unter Umständen da in dem Sun-Portfolio für IBM irgendwas zu holen ist. Da kenne ich mich jetzt nicht aus. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da jetzt für große Dinge da jetzt von Sun verkauft werden, die halt wirklich fürs Business relevant sind. Keine Ahnung, das muss auch nicht unser Thema sein. Kurz gesagt, die erste von 58 Fragen haben wir jetzt hier so mitbekommen.
Das könnte noch ein langer Podcast werden. Ich schlafe noch mal eine Runde.
Ja, ich meine, was hier so relevant ist, ist auch die gleiche Person. Kongo fragt gute Fragen, finde ich. Was kann Mac OS X von anderen Betriebssystemen lernen? Oh, das führt weit.
Nix.
Was? Das glaube ich ja nicht.
Na doch, weil, klar, man könnte ja sagen, es muss alles viel besser und schneller werden und so, aber ich glaube, jedes OS hat halt so seine Stärken und seine Schwächen. Und die Stärken, glaube ich, von OS X ist halt die leichte Bedienbarkeit für den End-User. Gar nicht mal so für den Power-User, da hat es halt auch schon so seine Menge, aber so für meine Mama, würde ich mal behaupten. Obwohl, die kriegt immer noch keinen, aber das hört die jetzt ja auch nicht, weil dann müsste ich die supporten, habe ich keinen Bock. Jedenfalls, da sind die Stärken. Wenn man jetzt versucht, noch andere Stärken mit ins Boot zu holen, ich glaube, man kann nicht alle Stärken gleichzeitig haben, das wird schwierig.
Alle nicht, aber es geht ja nicht darum, dass es alle geht, aber bestimmte Sachen könnte ich mir zum Beispiel schon gut vorstellen, was man sich bei anderen Sachen abgucken kann. Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt so einen Ubuntu-Linux nimmst oder auch schon einen FreeBSD, da kannst du halt so von der Kommando-Zeile aus dir halt das System so hochziehen, wie du es brauchst. Genau, die Konfiguration, die Customization, die Verschlankung des Systems auch und auch das Zurechtbiegen auf den konkreten Bedarf. Das kannst du halt auch automatisieren.
Power-User-Feature, ne?
Ja, das ist ein Power-User-Feature, aber das mag ja dann am Ende des Tages auch irgendwann mal relevant sein.
Aktualisierbarkeit finde ich ein spannendes Thema.
Also dieses Problem ist, dass die ganze Command-Line ist halt disjunkt von dem, was in der Oberfläche ist.
Na, nicht ganz. Es gibt dieses Default, mit dem man alle Preferenzes schreiben kann, weil es ja alles XMA. Dann für dieses...
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt eine neuere Version von Pearl haben will, dann kann ich nicht das Pearl in place... Ich kann dem OS nicht sagen, aktualisier mal diese Komponente. Ich meine, das machen sie dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder mit.
Weil gibt's halt einfach gar nicht als Update, richtig? Aber es ist ja so, wenn bei Freebies, dann das neueste Pearl nicht in den Ports auftaucht, dann kannst du da auch erst mal nichts machen. Klar. Du kannst dann das Pearl von Hand runterladen und selber installieren, dann kommt es dann mit deinen Ports durcheinander. Und das kannst du auf OS X auch machen. Also du bist da immer abhängig von dem Port-Maintainer. Und in dem Fall hier ist es bei OS X halt Apple.
Na ja, aber es gibt...
Du hast ja eigentlich auch recht.
Es gibt für Ubuntu und Konsorten, gibt es halt dieses Abpaketverwaltung, die wir alle ja...
Ja klar, weil da Hoshis sitzen, die auch kein Leben haben und den ganzen Tag irgendwie ihre Ports maintainen und so.
Aber es ist doch super zu wissen, also wenn es eine zentrale Infrastruktur für sowas gibt, wo ich einen Befehl habe in meinem Betriebssystem und alle meine Programme sind auf dem Stand.
Das gibt es ja bei Mac, das heißt Software-Update.
Das geht nur für Apple-Programme.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Und das geht nicht für Third-Party-Programme. Das finde ich ein bisschen schade.
Aber dafür gibt es eigentlich die Darwin-Ports, oder? Es ist ja das Packagesystem so.
Ja, also... Es war nicht das beste Beispiel.
Ja.
Fällt mir noch ein anderes ein.
Genau.
Also ich finde, da könnten sie was lernen. Das ist doch ein super Beispiel, wo sie was von anderen Betriebssystemen lernen könnten.
Besseres Portsystem. Ja, vielleicht.
Also...
Eins von Apple halt, maintained. Aber das haben die ja mehrmals angefangen. Es gab ja auch bei 10.3 oder irgendwann gab es dafür dieses Darwin-Ports, mal sogar ein Installer-GUI. War mit irgendwie dabei beim System. Irgendso einer Beta vorher.
Am System war das dabei?
Richtig mit GUI und so hast du geklickt und dachte, das ist alles, was du sonst irgendwie komisch, was auch mal bei den Darwin-Ports eingestellt werden musst.
Also ich weiß, dass es bei Darwin-Ports ein GUI gibt, aber dass das mit dem System geliefert wurde?
Das war bei Apple mit dabei. Und das wurde aber irgendwie wieder eingestellt und dann haben sie es irgendwie gelassen. Es kann auch sein, dass es der Vorgänger von Darwin-Ports war. Wir haben ja auch schon mehrmals gewechselt jetzt, oder?
Nein. MacPorts heißt es jetzt. Das war mal Darwin-Ports und jetzt heißt es MacPorts.
Okay, bei vielen Seiten steht immer noch Darwin-Ports.
Ja, sicherlich. Aber jetzt heißt es einfach MacPorts und hatte ja letztes Mal schon darauf hingewiesen, seit der letzten Release, die 1.7. Also jetzt kann man das richtig benutzen. Funktioniert jetzt ganz gut mit dem Upgrading und so weiter. Ich hab jetzt keine gute Antwort darauf.
Ich hab noch was, was sie von eigenem Betriebssystem lernen könnten, und zwar vom iPhone-Betriebssystem, den App Store. Den könnten sie in irgendeiner Form gerne mal auf den Mac portieren. Also ein schönes, einfaches Prinzip, mit dem ich, um Entwicklern Programme zu verkaufen, also damit ich als Entwickler meine Programme schön einfach einstellen kann. Und ich mir keine Sorgen um den Vertrieb machen muss.
Mit Seriennummernverwaltung und mit irgendwie gelockt aufs System?
Also ich möchte noch gerne Alternativen dazu haben. Ich möchte nicht, dass es wie offiziell auf dem iPhone ist, dass ich nichts, dass ich nur darüber kaufen kann, aber als zusätzliche Möglichkeit, um mir Programme runterzuladen, finde ich das großartig.
Ich glaube, ich würde das auch gut finden. Vor allem würde ich das als Entwickler gut finden.
Total.
Weil natürlich für die Entwickler ist gerade dieser ganze Aufwand der Distributionenbewerbung und vor allem so dieses Einkaufen lassen, natürlich ein echtes Ding. Aber es müsste sehr viel mehr können als der App Store auf dem iPhone. Also allein schon diese Beschränkung, eine Applikation, ein Gerät wäre so nicht zu halten. Du müsstest halt auch diese Funktionalität der Lizenzierung auf mehrere Systeme mit drin haben, mit der Möglichkeit halt, andere Systeme rauszunehmen und wieder reinzunehmen.
Also eher so wie bei iTunes, würde ich mal sagen, das Ganze machen. Ich finde auch, es müsste zum Beispiel besser verlinkbar sein. Was mir am App Store ein bisschen fehlt ist, irgendwie ist der Kontakt zwischen, beim App Store der Kontakt zwischen Entwickler und Nutzer komplett flöten, weil der App Store tut gerne so, als ob er die einzige Instanz wäre. Natürlich wird der Name des Entwicklers nochmal erwähnt. Das könnten sie ruhig ein bisschen besser machen. Also da kann man noch eine Menge lernen, aber so dieses prinzipielle Prinzip. Also ich finde es immer ein bisschen schade, dass bei Programmen, die es sowohl fürs iPhone als auch für ein Mac gibt, es ist gerne so, die iPhone-Version kostet einen Dollar oder zwei und die Mac-Version kostet dann 10 Dollar oder 20 Dollar. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Menge dem geschuldet, dass es einfach nicht so schönes Einkaufsprinzip gibt.
Deshalb meine Frage, ob wenn man ein Mac-Programm auch für einen Dollar anbietet, also da muss man natürlich auch sicherstellen, dass es auch über so einen Shop easy gekauft werden kann, sonst geht es ja auch irgendwie unter. Aber ob vielleicht nicht dann so für kleine Billigspielchen auch plötzlich 100.000 Mac-Freaks irgendwie für drei Tage dieses Spiel irgendwie zocken, dafür diesen einen Dollar bezahlen und am Ende mehr verdient, als wenn er es irgendwie für 10, 20 Dollar verzockt. Und ja, das ist halt nur so ein paar kaufen, weil wer kauft schon so ein Minispiel für 10 Dollar? Macht ja niemand. Also diese Mini-Apps sind schon eigentlich, oder die Mini-Preise sind schon wichtig eigentlich.
Na, wie toll das funktionieren kann.
Also ich denke mir vor, Desktop Tower, die Fans im Club geht es gerade wieder voll los, würde irgendwie so ein, zwei Dollar kosten. Das würde doch auch jeder kaufen. Du bist sofort angefixt bei diesem Game. Jetzt ist es halt ein Flash-Spiel, okay, aber...
Also ihr kennt ja vielleicht...
Sehe ich genauso.
Ihr kennt ja vielleicht so Dienste wie Maczot, heißt das glaube ich, wo man Programme, die so für einen Tag ein Programm saubillig anbieten. Und... Maczot? Z-O-T.
Ich mach unsere höhere Desktop-Tower-Defense süchtig.
Mal gucken, erstmal da link reinschmeißen. Und dieses... Ja, also zum Beispiel, oder MacHeist gibt es ja auch jetzt gerade, läuft aktuell glaube ich noch. Dieses Mal wieder so und so viele Programme für 39 Dollar. Hast du es gekauft? Ich habe es nicht gekauft, weil irgendwas mit meinem Paypal-Account nicht hingehauen hat. Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer.
Ist es denn jetzt vorbei schon?
Ich hoffe noch nicht. Ich hoffe, das läuft noch. MacHeist läuft nicht mehr.
Ich habe es gekauft.
Du hast es gekauft?
Ja, aber ich habe es erst gekauft, nachdem BoingTV freigeschaltet war. Ich wollte es nicht gewesen sein.
Wie du wolltest es nicht gewesen sein?
Na ja. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie gut das jetzt für diese Entwickler eigentlich wirklich ist.
Also ich habe mal mit einem Entwickler gesprochen, der dessen Programm über Maxsort verkauft worden ist. der meinte, also es ist unglaublich, also du nimmst, es läuft ungefähr so rauf, dass man ungefähr die Hälfte oder ein Drittel von dem, das kostet, was es normalerweise kostet, also wenn ich es über die Webseite koste, koste ich gerne mal 30 Dollar und ich krieg's dann bei Maxsort für 10 Dollar. Davon bleibt dann mindestens die Hälfte bei Maxsort. also sozusagen, es kommt höchstens ein Viertel beim Entwickler tatsächlich an.
Aber er verkauft halt viel mehr.
Aber er verkauft an einem Tag so viel wie sonst nicht in drei Monaten. Und du hast natürlich am Ende trotzdem den ganzen Support und so weiter. Also du hast dann eine viel größere Kundenbasis, die auf einmal auf dich einstürzt und die auf einmal ihre Probleme haben und so was, was das Ganze wieder ein bisschen fischi macht, aber sie verdienen, die haben einen Tag einen Umsatz von 4000 Dollar gemacht.
Na gut, aber es kommen ja noch mehr Sachen dazu. Es ist ja nicht nur, wie viel du da sozusagen jetzt verdienst im ersten Schub, sondern du musst ja danach auch für diese ganze riesige Kundenbasis theoretisch Support anbieten. Also das zieht ja auch noch Kosten nach sich, wo du halt einfach pro Nase weniger eingenommen hast.
Aber auch Gewinneventure, wenn die dann auf die nächste Version updaten und so, weil sie es wirklich cool finden.
Kann sein, muss aber nicht.
Und viele davon, ich denke mal auch, dass viele davon, die beim Mac heißt kaufen, also wirst du jetzt alle Programme benutzen, also nur bestimmte.
Nö, man nutzt höchstens einen Bruchteil von.
Ja, haben sozusagen viele Programme von dir so einen minimalen Anteil bekommen, aber du nutzt das gar nicht, machst auch bei denen keinen Stress und so weiter und so fort. Also ich denke mal schon, dass es schon...
Klar, klar, klar. Dann muss man allerdings auch noch sehen, dass es ja auch noch so einen Marketing-Aspekt gibt. Und zum Beispiel ist es eben so wie in der gesamten Produktwelt, Dinge wollen auch manchmal ihren Preis haben. Ja, und wenn du halt ein Programm, was einen gewissen Wert hat, in so einem Bundle anbietest, ja, was weiß ich, im Falle von Boing's TV, was ja schon so etwas umfangreicheres Software ist, die kostet dann irgendwie 200 Dollar normalerweise. Und auf einmal soll es nur noch ein Bruchteil von 39 Dollar wert sein. Dann denken sich natürlich alle Leute, die jetzt irgendwie davor stehen, so ach, da warte ich doch mal lieber, bis das mal wieder für 2,50 Euro angeboten wird. Wenn du es nicht brauchst. Offensichtlich kann diese Software ja nicht so viel wert sein.
Ist ja anscheinend offensichtlicher. So viel sei der Boingst-Typie, das ist ja nicht bei McTie's mit reingegeben.
Naja, jetzt bist du aber schon in dieser Denke, obwohl es durchaus sein kann, dass die Software ja das wert ist.
Also du hast ja gekauft, weil 200 waren ja anscheinend zu teuer. Du wolltest es irgendwie billiger haben.
Was nicht heißt, ja gut, ich meine derzeit habe ich jetzt keine konkrete Anwendung dafür, weil ich mache keine Videopodcast.
Aha, also hat er schon wieder Geld verdient, obwohl du es eigentlich sonst nie gekauft hättest.
Sicherlich, aber Geld ist nicht alles. Ja, sondern es ist halt auch noch die Support-Frage, es ist auch noch später die Frage, wie schneidet das Projekt in the long run ab? Weil davon werden die sich auf jeden Fall nicht ernähren können. Also dieser Umsatz, den sie jetzt hier gemacht haben, und das sind, was weiß ich, wie viele Lizenzen sind da rübergegangen? 80.000, 100.000? Kann es sozusagen sein, dass jetzt ihr Markt auch leer ist? Ja, dass sozusagen alle Leute, die durchaus erwogen haben, Boeing TV auch für den vollen Preis zu kaufen, weil das ist ja auch noch relativ neu, dass die jetzt gesagt haben, oh schön, super, 39 Dollar habe ich jetzt irgendwie gekauft, und ihnen sind halt jetzt 300 oder 400 oder 500 Customer entgangen, die sehr wohl auch 200 Dollar dafür bezahlen.
Also sind doch wie 10 Programme, von den 40 Dollar geht die Hälfte an den Mac-Heist-Macher und die anderen 20 Dollar werden auf 10 Programme verteilt, also 2 Dollar pro Programm oder wie?
Wobei da ein bisschen mehr abkriegen, das wird auch nicht so, das wird auch nicht aufgesplittet, wie das ist. Also das ist, das verhandeln die unter sich. Ich nehme an, dass die relativ, also das wird so.
Muss ja aber irgendwie so ungefähr so sein, denn wenn er mehr kriegt, kriegt er 3, also viel mehr kann es ja da nicht sein.
Also ich würde sagen, er kriegt so 3-4 Dollar pro Version.
Anstatt 200 ist schon ganz schön krass.
Und aber wenn man bedenkt, dass die jetzt mal eben dafür, sagen wir mal, nehmen wir mal 100.000 Lizenz verkauft worden, weil es sich einfach rechnet, dann haben die mal eben 300-400.000 Dollar Umsatz gemacht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich mehr als irgendwie...
Und dafür hätten sie einige Lizenzen verkaufen müssen, so regulär. Und was bei mir zum Beispiel der Fall ist, das sind ja oft dann bei MacHeist nicht upgradbare Versionen. Also ich hab nämlich zum Beispiel mal das Programm JummyFTP heißt das.
Da hat einer ein Interview gepostet mit dem Boing-Küken.
Also da hab ich mal ein... JummyFTP war bei MacHeist dabei und ist ein FTP-Client, von dem ich vorher nie was gehört hatte und hätte ich mir auch nie gekauft, weil da gibt es die üblichen Transmit und Transmission und auf die war ich fixiert und ja, dann hatte ich den dann rumliegen und dann hab ich ihn mal benutzt und fand ihn gar nicht schlecht und er konnte plötzlich das, was ich wollte und seitdem bin ich JummyFTP-Nutzer und dann kam irgendwann die nächste Version und mit der war ich wegen meinem Bundle-Angebot, war ich dann außen vor und dann hab ich mir das Programm die Vollversion gekauft. Also insofern, so kann es natürlich auch gut laufen, dass wir jetzt wissen, in zwei Wochen kommt eh die Version 1.5 oder in zwei Monaten und vielleicht können wir ja genug Leute anfixen und wer da nicht angefixed ist und sagt, ja, ach Gott, wegen der 200 Dollar, der hätte es wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht gekauft. Aber das meine ich auch gar nicht. Also ich finde, dass Software generell, also nicht generell billiger werden müsste, aber es gibt so Programme, wenn ich zum Beispiel Adobe Photoshop angucke, das ist, was kostet dieses Creative Studio irgendwie 2000 Euro oder sowas? Das ist ein absurder Preis.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch wirklich eine Monster-Software. Also wirklich eine Profi-Software. Ein normalsterblicher braucht eigentlich nicht so ein riesen Ding.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich kenne jetzt glaube ich unglaublich viele Profis, die es als Robkopie einsetzen, weil es so teuer ist und sich so unglaublich schwer rentiert. Ich glaube, die könnten durchaus mindestens 10x so viele Nutzer haben, wenn die Software ein Zehntel des Preises kosten würde und sie würden sich dabei nicht viel kaputt machen.
Aber die Debatte ist auch schon so alt wie der 64er. Also das war schon immer so, dass die User dann immer sagten, wenn sie es billiger machen würden, würden mehr Leute das verkaufen. Ich denke, die wissen schon genau, wo so ihr Preis sein muss.
Nö, das glaube ich gerade bei EttoBi, die wissen das überhaupt nicht. Die haben schon immer 2000 Euro dafür genommen.
Du meinst, du weißt es besser?
Ich glaube, ich weiß was besser, ja. Das glaube ich allerdings nicht. Man sieht doch, wo sich so die Preise auf dem iPhone einpendeln.
Aber das sehen die doch auch alle. Das sind doch Profis. Ich meine, das sind EttoBis inzwischen, wie viele Milliarden Dollar kommen?
Ach komm, ja. Und genau das macht Firmen so unglaublich beweglich. Ich glaube, die wissen...
Aber guck mal, die sind auf jeden Fall auch auf Gewinnmaximierung ausgelegt. Wenn die wüssten, wir würden dann was für die Hälfte verkaufen, würden wir mehr als die doppelte Anzahl verkaufen, dann würden die das doch machen.
Nee, da müsste sich einer hinstellen, müsste sagen, wir könnten vielleicht zehn Prozent mehr Gewinn machen, wenn wir das Programm zu einem Zehntel des Preises verkaufen. Wenn es klappt, dann klopft mir, wenn ich Glück habe, jemand auf die Schulter und sagt, wow, wir haben zehn Prozent mehr Gewinn gemacht. Wenn es schief geht und wir deswegen nur noch halb so viel Gewinn machen, dann bin ich mein Job los. Also halte ich lieber die Schnauze. So sieht es aus bei so einer großen Firma aus.
Also dafür haben die doch zum Beispiel das Photoshop Express und lauter so eine Schnick Schnack Software wurde das auch schon so ein bisschen.
Photoshop, meinst du dieses Elements oder meinst du dieses diese Web?
Express, da gab es doch so eine kleine Mini-Version von Photoshop, oder?
Also heißt es nicht Express. Elements. Das heißt das immer bei Apple. Photoshop Elements, ja. Das ist eine andere Software.
Das ist eine komplett andere Software. Ihr habt überhaupt nichts mit Photoshop zu tun.
Und von Photoshop selbst gibt es keine so abgespeckte Version? Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass die schon da irgendwie ihre Business-Dinge machen. Natürlich, perfekt kannst du den Punkt auch nicht treffen, aber die bewegen sich schon da, wo es schon so hinhaut.
Ich glaube, die haben einfach, dass Quark wäre fast dran Pleite gegangen, dass sie so einen unglaublich fetten Preis genommen haben, der so absurd hoch war.
Wie viel hatten die?
Das, ich glaube Quark Express hat so als Software, die das, was sie konnte, extrem gut konnte, aber darüber hinaus gar nichts konnte. Ich glaube 4000, ich weiß nicht, D-Mark oder Euro gekostet. Was hat denn was gekostet?
Quark Express.
Und dann hat Adobe genau diesen Markt aufgeräumt damals mit InDesign, die dann plötzlich Features hatten, von denen sie alle lange geträumt hatten, zu einem Bruchteil des Preises. Und die waren so eine gewisse Arroganz.
Du meinst, das haben sie jetzt wegen des Preises gemacht?
Na ja, auch wegen der Features. Quark war einfach, die waren Standard, die dachten, sie wären nicht verdrängbar, sie könnten jeden Preis nehmen, ohne Support zu bieten, ohne neue Features anbieten zu müssen und sind halt eines Besseren belehrt worden. Und ich glaube, das könnte Adobe eines Tages auch so ergehen.
Ja, also ich glaube, Nachrichten des Todes von Adobe sind noch etwas überzogen.
Die sind verfrüht, ohne Frage.
Adobe ist doch wirklich auch eine Multimilliarden-Dollar-Kompagnie, oder?
Ja, die haben PDF, und die haben Flash, und die haben eine Menge. Und es ist ja nicht so, als ob sie sich dem Web komplett verweigern würden. Die sind ja auch gerade mit Adobe Air, und die haben, glaube ich, jetzt auch so ein Online-PDF-Erzeugtool und sowas. Also da sind sie ja, bemühen sich ja durchaus. Also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass die morgen pleite sind. Ich würde sagen, ich glaube, die könnten durchaus genauso viel verdienen, wenn so ein Zettel des Preises das kosten würde und hätten einen Haufen mehr legaler Nutzer.
Wie gesagt, also...
Aber nicht zehnmal mehr, das ist halt das Ding.
Software...
Aber nicht zehnmal mehr.
Ja, ja, das denke ich auch nicht.
Warum nicht?
Weil Adobe, glaube ich, den möglichen Markt schon weitgehend abdeckt. Also jeder, der diese Software braucht, hat sie auch.
Legal, aber nicht legal.
Du könntest dann auch ein Zehntel vielleicht immer noch nicht kaufen.
Ich hab in Agenturen und entsprechenden Firmen gearbeitet. Das ist ein Bruchteil dessen. Und natürlich sind das ein Unterschied, ob ich 2000 Euro für irgendwas latze oder 200 Euro für irgendwas latze. Während ich...
Aber zehnmal mehr User, die das kaufen, ist schon ganz schön fett. Also das ist 1000 Prozent.
Also wie gesagt, ich kenne Läden, die kaufen eine Adobe CS3-Lizenz und installieren die auf 30 Rechner. Und natürlich, wenn die Software einen Zehntel dessen kosten würde, oder auf 50 Rechner, dann würden die schon eher erwägen, das wirklich auf einen Rechner zu installieren. Ich glaube, das ist durchaus nicht komplett.
Meine Erfahrung mit solchen Firmen ist, dass wenn es dann einen Zehntel kostet, dass sie dann immer noch einen kaufen und dann halt nur einen Zehntel ausgeben, weil die eigentlich sowieso nicht bereit sind, da irgendwas zu investieren.
Und die Firmen, die schon alle ihre Rechner damit ausstatten, die müssen ja auch nur noch die gleiche Anzahl kaufen und zahlen nur wenig. Also bei denen wird es dann nicht mehr. Also ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so einfach.
So einfach ist es natürlich nicht. Darum trauen sie sich auch nicht.
Aber lass uns, werden wir nie rausfinden.
Genau. Soll ich noch mal eine Frage raussuchen?
Wir haben ja keinen richtigen Themen.
Na, was hast du denn noch auf deiner Liste?
Meine Liste? Max, gibst du mir meine Liste?
Du hast aber mal keine.
Ah, warte mal, hier, die ist durchsichtig. Ich war nicht leicht zu finden.
Gab es keine News?
Ja, es gibt natürlich so News, aber ich meine, wollen wir uns jetzt über iTunes, HD-Movie, Rentes irgendwie unterhalten?
Es gibt AI-Hoo... Nee, wollen wir nicht.
Das finde ich jetzt nicht so spannend. Wir können uns auch über Max komisches Poken unterhalten.
Poken, Poken, Poken!
Aber sag mal hier...
Kannst du mal erzählen, was das soll? Ja, also Pokens, das war ja so, das war ja so das Schnuffi-Accessoire auf der Republik war.
Dortin hat das irgendwie auf irgendeinem Barcamp. Brian Ruhr war ja vor ein paar Wochen... Ist das so ein Tamagotchi-Dink? Ich hab sie in der Hand.
Da ist eins.
Tamagotchi-Dink.
Nee, das ist kein Tamagotchi-Dink. Das kostet 15 Euro, ist so ein kleines Ding, hat bei mir so einen Totenkopf drauf.
15 Euro?
Ja, 15 Euro.
Da kriegt man einen 64er bei eBay für.
Ja, aber ein 64er bei eBay, der passt auch nicht ans Schlüsselpunkt ran. Außerdem hat das Ding mehr Rechenleistung. Und das hat ja so eine Hand, wie man sieht, so ein stilisierter. Und wenn jemand anders auch mit dem Poken ankommt, dann hält man die zusammen und dann leuchtet die Hand so grün. Und dann hat man einen Kontakt hergestellt.
Für so Singles, dass man so da reinschreibt, was man so will.
Nee. Und dann zieht man die Kappe ab.
Das heißt nicht Single, das heißt Web 2.0-Aktivist.
Und dann zieht man hier diese Kappe ab, die es oben drauf hat. Und dann kommt da unten ein USB-Anschluss raus. Und das steckt man dann in seinen Rechner rein und dann wird ein Volumen gemountet auf dem Desktop. Und da ist ein HTML-Datei drauf. Und die HTML-Datei klickt man doppelt an. Und dann kommt man auf eine Webseite, wo man alle Leute sieht, mit denen man mit diesem Ding Kontakt hat. Und das heißt, wenn man auf so einer Konferenz wie der Republika rumkommt.
Eine HTML-Seite oder eine URL?
Eine HTML-Seite, die ein Redirect auf eine URL macht. Ah, verstehe. Um das möglichst einfach zu machen. Und also wirklich ein Prinzip, was auf jedem Betriebssystem funktioniert. Und dann kommt man auf eine Seite und sieht die Kontakt, die man im Tag über hat. Und man braucht also keine Visitenkarten mehr auszutauschen.
Moment, du steckst dieses Ding in deinen Rechner. Auf diesem Teil, da liegt ja nicht nur diese HTML-Datei rum, sondern da liegen auch noch diese Daten rum, diese ID's von anderen Pokens.
Na ja, die sind in der URL entkodiert.
In einer einzigen URL sind alle drin, die man gesammelt hat.
Genau, man sammelt nicht die eigentlichen Daten, sondern man sammelt nur die ID von den Dingern.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt 1000 Pokens bekommelt habe?
Du kannst 64 maximal auf einen Schlag. Und danach musst du reinstecken und neu befüllen.
Weil nicht mehr in die URL reinpasst.
Und was macht das Gerät, wenn ich die 65. da reinspeicher?
Dann leuchtet die LED rot statt grün oder so. Also es gibt verschiedene Fehlermeldungen. Sozusagen, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Wie viele Leute hatten auf der Republike auch so ein Ding?
Unglaublich viele. Also ich hab jetzt, wie viele Kontakte hab ich? Ich kann ja hier nochmal, wie heißt diese? Ich kann mir die URL von denen nie merken. doyopoken.com ist die. Die Webseite ist, um es mal freundlich auszudrücken, verbesserungsbedürftig. Und ich hatte, ich weiß nicht, so 120 Kontakte habe ich auf der Republika gemacht darüber. Und war aber überhaupt nicht der beste. Also es gibt sicherlich Leute, die haben da viel, viel mehr gemacht. Ich hab's jetzt halt jetzt hier zugangstatt nicht drin.
120.
So Pi mal Daumen. Und eigentlich ist das eine ganz typische Methode. Also man kann auf der Webseite, kann man dann angehen.
Aber hast du nicht sozusagen mit jedem, der überhaupt einen Poken hatte, gleich ausgetauscht, weil er eins hatte?
Man hat mit sehr vielen Leuten, weil sie eins hatten, dann hat man dann mal eben so Arsch zusammengehalten.
Kamen nicht auch so Leute angelaufen, die dann einfach ihr Poken an deinen Poken halten wollten?
Es wurde schon eine Menge rumgepokt. Und ungeschützt.
Wenn ich sagen würde, du hast ein schönes Körper, würdest du das gegen mich halten?
Genau, also es gab sehr viel ungeschütztes.
Welcher Film?
Multi-Python. Wunderbare Welt der Schwerkraft.
Reste poken hab ich.
Nein, das ist das ungarische englische Wörterbuch. Mein Luftgießenfahrzeug ist voller Ahle. Das kennst du nicht denn?
Der bekannteste, der berühmteste Multi-Python-Sketch überhaupt, wahrscheinlich neben dem toten...
Da kennst du dich vor dieser Groß... Vor dieser Ungar irgendwie reinkommt und dann dieses kleine Handbuch in der Hand, also er kommt in ein Tabakwarenladen und sagt irgendwie, wo man fängt er denn eigentlich an? Mein Luftgießenfahrzeug ist voller Ahle, war das schon das zweite, ne?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es anfängt. Wir können es mal raussuchen.
Weil Hovercraft ist full of Eels. So, und der verzweifelte Tabakbesitzer versucht, ihn darauf hinzuweisen, dass er halt in einem Tabak-Laden ist. Und dann kommt dann immer wieder das nächste. Ja, es ist ganz lustig.
Weil jemand gefälschte, ungarisch-englisch-Wörter-Bücher verkauft hat.
Genau, der wird dann später vor Gericht gestellt und ja ja, beschuldigt, dass er das getan hätte.
Gibt es auf YouTube, guckt es euch klar ein.
Es gehört zur Grundbildung. Wenn du so viel Zeit in deinem Keller verbringst und nicht rausgehst und mit Leuten sozialisierst und deine Poken-IDs austauschst, müsstest du eigentlich genug Zeit haben dafür.
Also ich finde diese Pokens auf jeden Fall, das ist...
Ich habe mit Grauen festgestellt, dass es keine Mailboxen mehr gibt.
Also jede Wette zum 26C3 wird das Ding durchgehackt sein, ohne Ende, weil die Verschlüsselung, ich kenne jemand, der hat sich ein bisschen mit dem Ding auseinandergesetzt, die Verschlüsselung ist nicht stark und der Schlüssel wird bestimmt gehackt werden und dann kann man da beliebige ID's fälschen und weiß ja teuer, wie wir das alles machen. Das wird bestimmt alles kommen. Ist also nicht jetzt was, wo ich auf große Sicherheit achte.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für eine Funk-Kommunikation?
Das ist ein RFID-Chip. So NFC-Technologie. Hier ist ein RFID-Chip drin, der ist rein passiv. Den könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich auch mit entsprechender Technik remote auslesen. Und es ist ein kleiner Empfänger drin. Und der Empfänger wird magnetisch aktiviert, sobald ein anderer in die Nähe kommt.
Magnetisch?
Magnetisch wohl. Damit, weil hier ist nur eine Knopfzelle drin. Und die muss ja auch halbwegs lange halten. Der kann ja nicht die ganze Zeit hier rum empfangen und rum senden. Und darum ist er eben sozusagen, die merken wohl magnetisch, wenn sie halbwegs in der Nähe sind. Und fangen dann an zu senden und zu empfangen. Der Knopf ist einfach nur, das ist in erster Linie die LED. Und dann kann man darüber noch verschiedene andere Funktionen, wie zum Beispiel, es gibt so ein TARM-Modus, dass ich mit jemandem so, den mag ich nicht, aber der besteht immer drauf, dass ich dann so kurz drücke. Das sieht so aus, als ob ein erfolgreicher Kontakt zustande gekommen wäre, aber der wird natürlich erscheinen. Quatsch, den muss ich erst freischalten, explizit, dass der mich sehen darf, infolgedessen. Also es gibt da noch so ein paar Funktionen mit drin.
Das heißt, der darf dann mit seinen schmierigen Griffeln nicht einfach so mit deinem Poken rumfielen.
Man kann nicht mit jedem rumpoken.
Okay, da haben sie ja schon mal ein ganz interessantes Feature eingebaut, weil ich dachte mir, das wäre dann am Ende des Tages das Hauptproblem, dass alle dann immer irgendwie mit deinem Poken rumfummeln wollen.
Es ist natürlich auf der Republika war das, hey, Poken, Poken. So fand ich es bisher ganz lustig, also es gibt ja seit Jahren reden wir darüber, dass irgendwie diese Visitenkarten austauschen und so was, dass es da mal was Neues geben müsste. Aber so richtig hat sich bisher nichts durchgesetzt und das Gerät ist einfach gerade so billig genug, um zumindest für den interessierten Nerd die 15 Euro für einen Spaß wert zu sein.
Kriegen wir dann eine entsprechende Applikation auf Basis von Bluetooth peer-to-peer auf dem iPhone?
Ja, aber dann muss man immer erst, also das ist wirklich, das ist von einer Geste her, ist das hübsch.
Du musst aber auch immer dabei haben.
Ja, du hängst es einfach an deinem Konferenz-Badge.
Ja, du kannst es aber auch nur mit anderen Leuten machen, die halt auch bereit sind, so ein hässliches Teil sich irgendwie umzuhängen.
Ja, das war auf der Republikar jeder und das wird...
Das hast du in deinem Telefon.
Wenn du ein iPhone hast.
Ja, für ein Telefon musst du dich nicht schämen, aber für so ein hässliches Poken musst du dich halt umdrehen.
Dann muss man sich nicht verschämen. Zum zweiten wird das... Jede Wette wird das über kurz oder lang mit einer Eintrittskarte für diverse Konferenzen verknüpft werden. Das heißt, du bekommst anstelle eines Bändchens oder sowas, bekommst du so ein kleines Teil. Warum nicht? Dann hast du das während der Konferenz. Du musst nicht für jeden neuen... Du kannst auch mehrere Pokens auf einen Account anlegen und dann packst du da... Du musst das ja gar nicht vorher machen. Du kannst den ganzen Tag...
Timme, wie heißen diese japanischen Freaks, die alle möglichen Gadgets haben?
Du meinst die...
Ja, die. Davon hat er so ein paar Gene in sich drin, glaube ich.
Ja klar, das haben wir alle.
Aber er hat da so von diesen Japanischen welche.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal gleich, der Begriff?
Weiß ich nicht. Otaku, da steht's.
Genau, Otakus. Okay, Chet weiß es.
Dann bin ich Teil Otaku.
Ich hab gewusst, dass es da gleich stehen wird.
Das ist super. Ich kann auch meine Augen ein bisschen mal zusammen.
Von Jean-Jacques Benet, der auch Diva gemacht hat.
Wie? Aber das ist nicht korrekt. Wieso ist das nicht korrekt? Jetzt sag uns mal, warum das nicht korrekt ist.
Was? Wieso? Es wird widersprochen. Der Chet widerspricht.
Na, einer sagt Otaku. Nee, zwei sagen Otaku. Und einer sagt, dass ich Otaku meine, aber das nicht korrekt ist.
Um jetzt nochmal ein paar Sachen zu dem Ding hier zu sagen. Was das Schöne daran ist, man kauft sich das und man braucht das nur zu aktivieren. Also man muss da so einen kleinen Zettel rausziehen und dann ist es erst mal aktiv. Und dann kann man den ganzen Tag schon rumpoken und wenn man dann abends irgendwann an seinem Laptop sitzt, schiebt man das einfach rein, schiebt dann erst seine Accountdaten hoch und trotzdem können alle, die man im Laufe des Tages gesehen hat, die Accountdaten sehen. Weil das ist ja nur die ID. Das ist schon eine hübsche Idee, dieses Poken-Ding. Das ist nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss, aber das ist das erste, was ich überzeugend finde in dem Bereich. Und irgendwie auf iPhone-Basis, wo dann zwei Leute dastehen und erstmal ein iPhone-Programm aktivieren müssen und siehst du mich jetzt und bist du Bluetooth-Gerät sowieso? Nein, das ist der dahinten. Ich glaube, das funktioniert. Das wird nicht so intuitiv. Es kann nicht so intuitiv sein. Und wird so bald nicht so kommen.
Es gibt übrigens doch Photoshop Express.
Ist das die Website-Version?
Oder wird gerade gemacht? Das ist eine auf Flash basierende Rich-Internet-Applikation. Das ist nicht wirklich eine Applikation, sondern mehr so ein Dienst.
Es gibt auch Pixler, das ist auch ganz hübsch. Das ist auch auf Flash basiert. Kann man auch im Web, also pixlr.com und dann hat man so eine einfache Bildbearbeitung im Webbrowser direkt drin.
Ist ganz möglich.
Gut, machen wir das mit dem Poken jetzt durch?
Durchgepuckt.
Furchtbare Name.
Man kommt um die sexuelle Kononisation nicht drum rum. Poken.
Poken ist ja eigentlich etwas, was ich auf dem C64 immer gemacht habe. Ja.
Aber auf dem nächsten Barkend werdet ihr was auch haben.
Ich fliege nochmal hier durch die Kommentare, weil da gibt es einfach mal interessante Anregungen. Und zwar gibt es eine ZFS-Frage, Dennis. Das geht an dich.
Was, wie, wo?
Mich?
Genau. Wie denn das so sei mit ZFS, mit Festplatten, die unterschiedlich groß sind in einem Pool.
Ach, Menschenskinder, ich muss nochmal gucken.
Na, kommt drauf an, was man damit machen will. Wenn man die stript, ist es egal. Also, sagen wir, du hast ein halbes Terabyte und ein ganzes Terabyte, dann stripsest, hast anderthalb Terabyte. Hast aber keine Redundanz. Wenn du natürlich einen Ray-Z machst, dann nimmt der immer nur, also, die kleinste als gemeinsames Ding. Das heißt, dass du nur zweimal, oder du musst halt, bei dem Ray-Z brauchst du ein bisschen mehr Platten als zwei, sonst lohnt es dir nicht. Sagen wir mal vier. Und du hast irgendwie zweimal ein halbes und zweimal einen Terabyte. Dann nimmt der von den Terabyte-Platten halt auch nur das halbe, weil es die gleiche Größe haben muss.
Eigentlich will man für sowas dann doch eher halbwegs gleich große Platten haben. Und was hier auch hinterfragt wird, was ich auch noch mal fragen wollte, ist nämlich, jetzt kommt ja dieses iSCSI hoch. Also SCSI über IP. Und damit sozusagen über Ethernet.
Da musst du eine Platte halt physikalisch nicht an dem Rechner dran haben, sondern kannst du das halt über IP ranholen, sodass du dann ein Block-Device hast, was aber eigentlich woanders ist.
Hast aber immer noch exklusiven Zugriff, also das ist nur ein Rechner, der das sozusagen macht. Es geht bloß über IP und du brauchst keine Firewire und keinen sonstigen Kram, sondern nimmst einfach deine Ethernet-Infrastruktur. Da gibt's ja jetzt auch diesen neuen Drobo. Drobo Pro.
Mit 8 Slots, ja. Hab ich vorhin noch ein ganz bisschen geguckt, aber es ist doch immer noch half S plus only, oder?
Ich glaube auch, dass sich da im Wesentlichen bei diesem Drobo Pro jetzt technisch von den Innereien her nicht so sehr viel getan haben. Das ist halt irgendwie groß und fett und schwer und passt jetzt irgendwie auch in 19 Zoll, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das ist halt für Leute, die irgendwie noch mehr Platz unterkriegen wollen. Aber das Ding hat eben Ethernet, unter anderem. Also er hat natürlich auch noch die ganzen anderen Kram. Aber du kannst eben das Ding eben auch einfach über Ethernet anschließen. Was natürlich schon ganz interessant ist, weil du sozusagen wie einen lokalen Rechner, wie eine lokale Festplatte hast. Aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie flexibel das ist. Ein iSCSI benötigt ja dann auch einen Treiber. Den gibt es bei Mac OS X noch nicht.
Gesehen habe ich sowas schon mal.
Sowas hast du schon mal gesehen?
In Disk Utility. Ist aber schon lange her, ist nicht mehr da.
Also es gab mal was.
Ich glaube, das war sogar zu Lepr-Zeiten. Da war ich noch kein Developer, glaube ich. Darf ich da drüber erzählen? Ist mir egal. Also ich habe sowas schon mal gesehen. Wahlmenü, iSCSI Support. Haben sie wieder entfernt. Ich glaube, wenn ZDFest kommt, ich glaube, dann kommt auch iSCSI.
Ich meine, die werden jetzt sicherlich das in ihren eigenen Treiber eingebaut haben bzw. einen eigenen Treiber mitliefern, um das zu machen. Das wäre natürlich generell eine interessante Funktionalität, die man einfach Geräte unabhängig haben möchte. Ja, aber das Problem ist halt immer noch dasselbe. Du hast halt immer noch HFS Plus drauf und du hast halt immer noch dieses merkwürdige Hin und Her-Verhalten. Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin da nach wie vor ausreichend abgeschreckt nach meinen ersten Experimenten mit diesem Teil. Weil ich würde dem nicht wirklich was wichtiges anvertrauen wollen. Also ist es irgendwie nicht.
Dem Drobo.
Ja, dem Drobo.
Was wir ja mal machen müssen, was mir gerade einfällt, ist Danke sagen. Und zwar Marcel hatte alias Subraum-Spalter auf Twitter, hat ja uns beim letzten Podcast versprochen, wenn wir es bis zum nächsten Morgen um elf schaffen, den Podcast online zu stellen beziehungsweise Tinder schafft, das ist ja mal die Arbeit, die Tim macht, dass er uns dann einen Kast Club Mate spendet.
Das hat er auch gemacht.
Das hat er gemacht. Ich bin sehr glücklich, ich hab ihn auf der Republika getroffen, er hat mir keinen Kasten Club Mate in die Hand gedrückt, wofür ich sehr dankbar bin, wegen Tragetechnik. Er hat mir einfach 20 Euro in die Hand gedrückt und die werden wir jetzt, wenn ich, ich hab heute dämlicherweise keine 20 Euro dabei, die werden wir jetzt demnächst mal in Club Mate umsetzen und dann sozusagen auf dich nochmal anstoßen, würde ich sagen.
Oder? Natürlich. Vielen Dank.
Du hast es wirklich als Rekordzeit dann geschafft. Der Podcast war ja dann nachts um drei noch online.
Ja, das war für mich ausreichend Motivation da, nicht noch einen Tag zu warten.
Und das muss ich auch mal sagen, das ist ja wirklich unglaublich, das läuft ja im Augenblick alles auf dem Spreeblickserver, dieser Podcast-Download und der Server ist da auch nicht optimal konfiguriert, das muss ich auch sagen, aber halbnachts drei kommt ein neuer Podcast raus und mit rein Download schafft ihr das erst mal, den Server in die Knie zu zwingen, für eine halbe Stunde oder sowas. Das sind beeindruckende Download-Zahlen, die zu Stande kommen.
Na ja, so ist das halt bei Podcasts, nicht wahr? Alle gleichzeitig.
Ja, aber halbnachts.
Also halb zwei oder wann war das?
Die Leute schalten einfach den Computer nicht mehr aus, egal ob das nachts oder tags läuft.
Du nicht? Ich schon. Ich klappe dann immer zu, wenn ich ihn brauche. Das machen viele Leute, die ich kenne.
Du klappst deinen Laptop zu?
Ja, ich klappe meinen Laptop zu. Zum Beispiel Zweckstransport.
Achso, da muss man ja.
Aber auch nachts.
Ich hab schon, glaube ich, vor einer zweistelligen Zahl von Jahren aufgehört, meine Computer auszuschalten.
Nee, ich lege mich einfach im Sleep-Modus.
Ist ja dasselbe.
Energiesch- Du klappst deinen Rechner nachts nicht zu?
Nein, natürlich klappe ich meinen Rechner nicht zu, weil er wird ja erstens gebackupt.
Stimmt, das dauert ja bei dir immer so ewig.
Und wenn er nicht läuft, was heißt ewig, also er wird halt am laufenden Meter gebackupt.
Ja, okay, also ich backupe ja, wecke ja meinen Rechner nur alle paar Wochen mal ab, oder alle paar Tage.
Echt?
Und den klappe ich nachts immer zu, klar. Ich gucke, wenn ich dann abends fertig bin, und dann wird er zugeklappt, und dann ist er bis zum nächsten Morgen im Sleep-Modus. Und das möchte ich jetzt auch allen Hörern empfehlen, wenn es da keinen guten Grund für gibt, weil das kostet ja auch eine Menge Strom. Das ist ja auch...
Das stimmt, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen aus Energiesparaspekten vielleicht ein bisschen...
Und so schnell wie die Dinge aufwachen, finde ich, spricht da auch nicht wirklich was dagegen, den Arm zuzumachen. Außerdem ist das dann das Adium weg, dann kann mich darüber niemand erreichen und sowas. Genau, mit Smart Sleep natürlich, selbstverständlich. Das kam hier gerade über Smart Sleep. Das ist auch von... Wie heißt denn der eigentlich? Der auch Jolly's Fast-Von-C geschrieben hat, der hat auch Smart Sleep geschrieben. Das ist so eine Software, mit der man... Und zwar ist ja, man hat ja... Standardmäßig schläft ja der Mac ein. Kann ich das kurz... Das schiebe ich mal kurz rein. Haben wir über Smart Sleep schon mal gesprochen?
Ich glaube, wir haben noch nicht drüber gesprochen. Ich habe mir das auch mal installiert, aber ich glaube, es hat meinen Reinstall nicht überlebt.
Das ist... Also wenn ihr euren Mac schlafen legt, dann speichert der den aktuellen RAM, wird der beibehalten. Und einfach, indem der Arbeitsspeicher weiterhin mit Strom versorgt wird. Und der Arbeitsspeicher wird zusätzlich nochmal auf die Platte geschrieben, dass wenn der Akku leer wird, während...
Hibernation...
.während der Rechner schläft, dass er dann wieder... Hibernation heißt das... .dass er definitiv, hibernation, dass er definitiv keinen Datenverlust hat. Dann kann er nämlich die Daten wieder von einer Festplatte herstellen, den Arbeitsspeicher. Und dadurch dauert das Schlafenlegen bei neueren Macs relativ lange. Früher ging das einfach ratzfatz. Und jetzt gibt es diverse Tricks, mit denen man das abschalten kann, dass er nämlich weiterhin einfach dieses Hibernate abschaltet und nur am Arbeitsspeicher speichert. Und das... ja, und Smart Sleep ist jetzt eine Software, die beim Schlafenlegen nachguckt, wie viel Batterie haben wir denn noch? Wenn ich noch viel Batterie habe, dann wird da wahrscheinlich bald den Rechner wieder aufklappen und dann gehen wir mal das Risiko ein und speichern es nur im RAM. Und wenn ich wenig Batterie habe, dann geht da genau den umgekehrten Weg, dann macht er nämlich den Hibernate und schaltet den Rechner danach aus. Und so, dass man möglicherweise noch ein bisschen länger die Energie hat. Find ich eine ganz hübsche Option. Kostet auch nichts das Programm.
Ist eine nette Sache, genau. Sagt zumindest seine Webseite.
Na dann vertrauen wir dir einfach mal.
So, ganz viele Leute fragen hier nach Synchronisation. Ich hab da ehrlich gesagt aber noch keine gute Antwort drauf gefunden. Irgendwo so einem Blog wurde ein Tool namens Unison empfohlen, was auch in den MacPorts ist. Ich bin allerdings noch nicht dazu gekommen, das mal zu testen, was sich sozusagen der Synchro-Geschichte annimmt. Also das installiert man auf Kommando-Zahlen-Ebene. Deswegen halt auch MacPorts. Aber dummerweise hat es halt den gleichen Namen wie ein anderes Unison, nämlich diesen Newsnet-Reader. So was gibt es ja auch noch. Von daher kann das jetzt schnell verwechselt werden. Aber ich hab keine Zeit gehabt. Ich war wieder mal viel unterwegs. Und von daher weiß ich da auch nicht sehr viel zu.
Ich will noch einen kleinen Hausraum-Tipp abgeben.
Oh ja, bitte.
Und zwar, ich hab mir 64er bei Ebay gekauft. Und eine Floppy und so. Jedenfalls.
Ein 64er.
War das alles schick verpackt und so. Aber was die Leute halt machen, sie drehen halt alle Kabel voll. Also sie rollen halt so zusammen. Und damit es sich nicht wieder auseinanderrollt, drehen sie das Ende dann nochmal durch. Kann man sich das ungefähr vorstellen so? Und ich glaube, nach jetzt jahrelanger Kabellage bei mir zu Hause, ich glaube das ist ganz schlecht, weil ich glaube man will Kabel gar nicht zusammen wickeln und rollen und noch ganz eng irgendwie umschlingen, weil wenn man die nämlich nicht zusammenrollt, ich zum Beispiel am Netzteil hier, ich pack das auch einfach immer unaufgerollt in meinen Rucksack, weil dann sind die Knickstellen nämlich auch immer an unterschiedlichen Stellen. Das verteilt sich halt besser, weil wenn du das immer gleich machst, den Knick, dann irgendwann ist es auch mal durch. Genau, deswegen einfach nicht aufrollen. Einfach irgendwo drin stopfen, so wie es gerade ist.
Dennis, Hausfrau, ein Tipp. Kabel einfach immer so in die Tasche stopfen.
Wenn man den Platz dafür hat.
Ich glaube, ein nicht aufgerolltes Kabel kann sich ja fast noch besser verteilen, als den runden Genubbeln, den du dir so machst.
Na ja, die sind ja immer alles so hartes Plastik und so. Tja, wir können auch heute einfach mal früher aufhören.
Also, Jolly, also der Patrick, der unter dem Namen Jolly, hier auch gerade im Chat, Jolly Jinks, gerade im Chat rumschreibt, schreibt auch, dass Smart Sleep schon vorher nachguckt und von der Batterie informiert wird, wann der entsprechende Level erreicht ist.
Und nicht erst in dem Moment.
Und nicht erst in dem Moment, wo man schlafen liegt. Ich glaube aber, das ist ein rein technisches Detail und hat praktisch keine Lauswurken.
Na gut, dass sich hier niemand für technische Details interessiert.
Aber das ist erst mit dem iPhone und mit dem Magneto-Dings, dass man dann einen Kompass hat, weil man angeblich dann bei Google Street View gleich nur noch das iPhone in die richtige Richtung hält und dann das passende Bild dazu kommt.
Du meinst, wir sollen jetzt doch noch ein bisschen Glaskugeln machen?
Klar!
Na dann?
Das ist unsere Berufung.
Also ich meine, was wir glaube ich schon mal sagen können, ist, die Kamera wird besser werden, sie wird Video aufzeichnen können.
Weil ja dieses Video-Interface da entdeckt wurde.
Weil das Video-Interface entdeckt wurde.
Und angeblich kann man auch schneiden und so.
Es sind genug Hinweise gefunden worden, dass man mit der neuen iPhone-Software auf jeden Fall Videos aufnehmen und schneiden können wird. Und ich würde Apple ja zutrauen, dass das ein Feature ist, was ausschließlich das neue iPhone bekommt.
Untergarantie. Ich wäre schon froh, wenn man mit dem Ding mal Fotos machen könnte. Das fände ich ja schon mal groß.
Ja, eine bessere Kamera. Also gibt es ja irgendwelche Gerüchte von 3,2 Megapixel Kameras und irgendwelchen 5 Megapixel Kameras? Die Apple im Großziel bestellt haben soll.
Die Megapixel, wie man ja auch überall hört, ist gar nicht so entscheidend. Entscheidend ist, dass die Linse ein Stück größer werden, damit mehr Licht einfällt. Ich glaube, das ist halt eher eine Sache, die würde Apple ein paar Euros kosten. Und dann lassen die sowas eher.
Nee, ich glaube, es wird eine Videofunktion geben. Und damit die Videofunktion da drin ist, muss die Videoqualität auch halbwegs was taugen. Und die machen nicht irgendwie, die wollen nicht so...
Ja, aber bei Video brauchst du nicht so eine hohe Qualität wie bei Fotos. Bei Fotos brauchst du eine viel höhere Qualität als bei Video.
Na ja, aber ich mache ja regelmäßig mal Quik. Quik ist dieser Dienst, dieser Internetdienst, wo man Live-Videos streamen kann. Vom Handy. Unter anderem auch vom jailbrokenen iPhone. Und die Qualität ist schon ziemlich lausig. Und die ist nicht so lausig, weil Quik das nicht besser könnte, sondern die ist so lausig, weil...
Quik macht Video.
Ja, ja, Quik macht Video.
Das iPhone hat aber keine Kamera, die für Video gedacht ist.
Ja, aber das ist...
Klar, dass man sich da über die Qualität beschwert, wenn das sozusagen gar nicht dafür gemacht ist. Das Ding kriegt doch gar nicht die Frameraten hin.
Doch, die Frameraten sind relativ okay.
Ja, wie sind die denn?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab sie nicht gemessen, aber...
Ich hab irgendwas gelesen von so 10 oder so.
Also das ist... Ich hab da mit ein paar Video-Übertragungen gemacht. Das ist... Handy-Kamera-Qualität. Und man hat...
Ja, was ich sage ist, du brauchst für Video, um den Eindruck zu haben, dass das Video okay ist, nicht so viel Auflösung, wie du brauchst, um den Eindruck von einem Foto zu haben, dass das Foto okay ist. Mehr wollte ich gar nicht sagen.
Aber die Kamera-Optik ist beim iPhone scheiße und die ist dringend verbesserungspolitisch.
Das ist auch nicht hell genug. Was mich am meisten stört, ist eigentlich die Latenz. Man tippt halt dann auf dieses Teil drauf, auf dieses Icon, dieses Touch-Interface. Und das, was du in dem Moment aber im Bildschirm siehst, ist nicht das, was fotografiert wird. Sondern er macht dann halt die Auslösung so viel später, dass man überhaupt gar keinerlei Bezug mehr hat zu diesem Sucher. Also den könnten sie eigentlich auch weglassen.
Na ja.
Ich frage mich, ob sie wirklich den Mumm haben, gerade bei Video. Sie konkurrieren im Prinzip in Richtung Einfachheit mit sowas wie diesem Flip, heißt das doch, diese One-Button-Video-Kamera. Das ist einfach. Einfach ist, du nimmst das Ding in die Hand, drückst auf den Knopf und nimmst ein Video auf. Du musst nicht groß drüber nachdenken, la la la. Auf dem iPhone finde ich den Vorgang des Fotomachens extrem kompliziert. Du musst es einschalten, musst es entriegeln, musst deine PIN eingeben. Dann musst du irgendwie durch fünf Bildschirms Seiten durchmarschieren, um irgendwie dann deine Kamera-Applikation zu finden. 30 andere sehen ähnlich aus. Dann startet das Ding, es dauert ewig, bis es überhaupt startet. Dann zeigt es dir irgendwie ein wuschiges Bild an, was unglaubliche Latenz hat. Schon wenn du es irgendwie so hin und her hältst, hat es Latenz. Dann hältst du es auf irgendetwas, was sich bewegt. Dann versuchst du diesen Miniatur-Button da in der Mitte zu treffen. Insbesondere wenn du versuchst, von dir selber ein Bild zu machen, ist es vollkommen unmöglich, überhaupt ein Bild auszulösen. Dann ist es halt noch nicht mal in dem Moment, wo du drauf tippst, auch das Bild, was du im Sucher siehst, sondern es ist was anderes, was später kommt.
Also das ist...
Es geht nicht.
Ich hatte ja vorher Generation von...
Es geht nicht. Meine Sony Ericsson-Kamera, die hatte einfach eine Taste dafür.
Das Handy meinst du? Das Sony Ericsson-Handy, genau.
Und sie können auch gleich diesen blöden Locker, der sich sowieso immer von alleine auslöst, können sie sowieso mal überarbeiten. Und wenn sie schon sowas Sinnfreies wie den da anbringen, dann können sie auch gleich eine Taste für...
Ich finde diesen Schalter, mit dem man den Klingelton ausschalten kann, den finde ich großartig. Ich habe früher nie bei anderen Telefonen den Klingelton ausgeschaltet, einfach weil es mir immer zu kompliziert war. Den findest du großartig. Ja, ich auch.
Ich schalte regelmäßig meinen Klingelton aus, wenn ich meinen Telefon in die Hosentasche stecke. Das merke ich dann in zwei von drei Fällen, dadurch, dass es brummt, wenn man das macht. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich das Teil in meine Hosentasche schiebe, geht halt dieser Schalter hoch, weil der halt übersteht.
Ja, ja, ich weiß welche Problematik du meinst, aber ich finde dieses, ich habe einen Schalter, den lege ich um, das kann ich auch im Meeting auch... Ah, ich habe es vergessen, brauche ich das Telefon nicht extra raus?
Ja, ich habe nichts dagegen, dass sie so einen Schalter machen, aber dieser Schalter ist scheiße, weil er schaltet von alleine. Und nicht dann, wenn ich schalte. Und ich will, dass ein Schalter von mir geschaltet wird und nicht selbst schaltet, weil dann kann man den Schalter auch weglassen und er könnte einfach randommäßig irgendwann mal den Klingelton ausschalten. Das hätte in etwa den gleichen Effekt.
Naja, bei dir, aber vielleicht kannst du ja auch an deiner... Tust du dein iPhone nicht in deine Hosentasche?
Und du willst mir erzählen, dass bei deiner Hosentasche dieser Schalter nicht automatisch umgelegt wird, wenn du ihn da reinschiebst?
Es passiert sehr, sehr selten.
Es passiert.
Es passiert, aber es passiert sehr, sehr selten.
Genau, es passiert. Das heißt, dieses Gerät ist nicht in einem definierten Zustand. Und zumindest nicht in dem definierten Zustand, von dem du glaubst, in dem es ist. Das geht nicht. Und Kamera, Taste. Man braucht dafür einfach eine Taste. Wenn dieses Teil eine Kamera hat, dann braucht es auch eine Taste dafür.
Ich find's eigentlich viel besser, so wie das Sony Ericsson gemacht hat. Die haben sowieso einen Linsenschutz vorne angebracht bei besseren Kamerahandys. Und indem du den zur Seite schiebst, wird diesen Linsenschutz die Kamera-Applikation gestartet. Und dann können sie sich meinetwegen auch die extra Taste sparen.
Das machen die nie.
Das werden die nicht machen. Das hat auch bei meinem Sony Ericsson dann nicht lange gehalten. Irgendwann war das Ding halt durch.
Du schanzt mit deinem Telefon relativ ruppig umzugehen. Das ging bei meinem gegen das.
Ich benutze halt meine Geräte auch.
Ach so, während ich sie nur zu Hause im Schrankraum liegen.
Ja, du feierst das immer noch.
Das sagt einmal das Nummer. Wenn ich sage, bei mir stürzen die Wärze, dann sagt er auch immer, ich würde ja nichts benutzen.
Ja, machst du ja auch nicht. Du hast ja nichts installiert. Na ja, meine Burgun-Energie ist Legion. Also da muss schon so ein Computer ganz schön was bringen, wenn er vor mir funktionieren möchte. Also im Katalog funktionieren die ja schon, aber vor mir gehen die alle mal schnell in die Knie.
Papa, guck mal, was ich gemeint habe.
Kennst du eigentlich einen guten RSS-Räder für das iPhone?
Ich benutze hier Gazette heißt der.
Gazetta?
Gazette, Gazette, der ist ähm...
Der kann aber nicht mit irgendwas auf dem Macintosh sinken, oder?
Der sinkt mit dem Google-Reader.
Der sinkt mit dem Google-Reader, das heißt, gibt es einen Google-Reader Desktop-Client?
Den kann man sicher selber bauen.
Nein, ich meine, gibt es ein Programm auf dem Macintosh, was mit Google-Reader sinkt?
Ich hab mir selber eins gebaut.
Ich hab einfach mit Fluid, mir einen Standalone RSS-Reader geschrieben. Kennst du Fluid? Das ist so dieses Programm, mit dem man Standalone, aus dem man aus Webseiten Programme machen kann.
Ja, aber dann brauchst du halt immer noch online. Ich rede von einem RSS-Reader, der halt auch offline funktioniert.
Ach so, dann brauchst du Google, wie heißt das, Google Gears?
Ich will das nicht in so einem Webbrowser benutzen. Ich will ein Macintosh-Programm haben. Gibt es so was?
Nö. Oder doch, es gibt kein Macintosh-Programm. Es gab mal so, da hat hier, wie heißt der Autor von Net News via Brand Simmons, der hat mal so darauf hingedeutet, dass die Firma, von der er aufgekauft worden ist, die hießen die gleich, die ja auch so im mobilen Bereich unterwegs sind, also im Bereich unterwegs sind, dass man seine RSS-Feeds online synchronisieren kann, dass die überlegt haben, das Ganze auch für einen Google-Reader zu machen.
Also mir wird hier gerade im Chat gesagt, dass Eventbox in der Lage ist, über Google-Reader zu sinken.
Ja, aber Eventbox ist kein full-blown RSS-Reader. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Feeds du abonniert hast, aber wenn das mehr als, sagen wir mal, 20 sind, dann wirst du mit Eventbox ziemlich sicher nicht glücklich werden. Ich hab das mal ausprobiert und ich fand's, ich hab's nach kurzer Zeit wieder aufgegeben. Aber ich bin wirklich, ich hab NetNews via geliebt, wie wahrscheinlich die meisten Mac-User als RSS-Reader und hatten dann irgendwann schweren Herzens aufgegeben für den Google-Reader. Und vermisse einige Features nach wie vor, aber an anderen Stellen ist Google-Reader dem ganzen so hauches Hoch überlegen, also zum Beispiel, was die Synchronisierung angeht, was die Suche angeht, dass man RSS-Feeds auch lesen kann, wenn man seinen Rechner gerade nicht anhat. Also, dass die auch, wenn ich im Urlaub bin, habe ich danach eben nicht nur die letzten 20 neuen Artikel von einem bestimmten RSS-Feed, sondern eben alle Artikel, die in der Zeit angefallen sind. Weil Google-Reader halt auch nachguckt, wenn ich meinen Rechner gerade nicht offen habe. Das hat schon einen Haufen Vorteile. Und das ist am Anfang sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig und Google ist evil und wir wissen das alle und das ist alles ganz brüchig. Aber so eine Cloud-Lösung sind in vielen Fällen die Desktop-Lösungen. Um einiges voraus.
Dennis sagt ja immer, Google wäre evil. Stimmt's? Ich benutze jetzt auch Google Groups.
Zum Google Groups? Damit kann man Mailinglisten verwalten, oder?
Ja, damit kann man sich irgendwie eine Mailingliste machen. Das scheint wirklich der einzige Dienst auf diesem Planeten zu sein, wo man sich mal eben eine Erträgliche Mailingliste mit einrichten kann.
Ich weiß nicht, bei Yahoo gab es doch auch so was, so Mailinglisten.
Funktioniert das nicht?
Ja, dieses E-Groups, was irgendwie immer alles ganz, ich weiß nicht, ich hab da irgendwann mal drinnen rumgeklickt und es war irgendwie alles ganz furchtbar. Also, ich hab nicht so viel Erfahrung damit gesammelt, aber ich hatte irgendwie das Gefühl, man muss sich dann auch anmelden, wenn du irgendwie Leute auf dieser Medialiste haben willst, müssen irgendwie alle einen Yahoo-Account haben.
Ach so schlimm, okay, das ist furchtbar.
Ich lasse mich gerne korrigieren, bei Google Groups ist es auf jeden Fall, ähm, es ist nicht so.
Haben wir schon mal über dieses Google-Sync gesprochen?
Ja, oder?
Welches Google-Sync?
Na dieses, dass man das Google für den Kalender und fürs Adressbuch ein Exchange-Account anbietet, mit dem man auf dem iPhone zum Beispiel alle seine Google-Kalendereinträge Overseer synchronisieren kann? Ja, hatten wir.
Letztes Mal.
Wenn ich mich nicht irre. Stimmt's, Dennis? Das Thema hatten wir, glaube ich.
Ich hab grad nicht aufgepasst.
So, du hast nicht aufgepasst. Ja, dann hab ich hier irgendwie, ähm, vor einer Weile bei Bits und so, hab ich noch irgendwie einen guten Tipp mitbekommen. Den kann ich hier auch gleich nochmal weitergeben. Schöner Hausfraunt-Tipp, genau. Und zwar gibt es eine HBCI-Client für das iPhone.
Ein HBCI-Client?
Hab ich letztens auch irgendwo gelesen.
Heißt, furchtbarer Name, iOutbank.
HBCI, das ist dieses lustige Bankformat, mit dem man...
Kontointerface. Also wenn du ein Konto hast, ein Bankkonto...
Das ist das, wo Money aus der Wand rauskommt, wenn ich die richtige... Ja, also...
Hat man ja, so von Zeit zu Zeit. Und dann kannst du halt, dieses iOutbank, das kostet irgendwie so 10 Euro, oder 9,99, oder irgendwie sowas. Und ja, das kann halt dann auf deine... auf dein Konto zugreifen. Und zeigt dir die Kontoauszüge an. Also zeigt dir sozusagen an, was so der aktuelle Stand ist und jeder einzelne Buchungsvorgang ist dann sichtbar mit so einem schönen blauen Punkt davor, welche du dir noch nicht angeschaut hast. Also liest dich dann so dein Konto, liest dich so ein bisschen wie in so einem RSS-Rider an.
Was für ein Desktop wäre mal praktisch? Kennt jemand eine schöne, gute Banking-Applikation für ein Desktop?
Denkt doch nicht immer gleich ab. Auf jeden Fall im nächsten Release versprechen sie halt auch die Möglichkeit, dass man Überweisungen darüber machen kann, was sehr interessant wird.
Also das Übliche, erstmal ein bisschen abwarten und dann zuschlagen.
Ich finde es jetzt schon praktisch.
Ansonsten, wir sind ja immer gerne bereit für, wie heißen die Installationen für uns so? Diese... So wie der mit dem Ur-Programm, der Flash, der uns hier glaube ich auch gerade zuhört, der uns auch so Nummern geschickt haben, damit wir sein Programm nicht kaufen müssen. Das kann man mit iOutbank natürlich auch machen.
Achso, du meinst, wir sind bestechlich?
Klar, aber sowas von...
Wirklich?
Für ein Bankprogramm?
Da muss ich doch ordentlich testen. Wie soll ich denn vorher ordentlich sagen, dass das wirklich toll ist? Bin jetzt noch nicht so überzeugt.
Achso, erst mal willst du das Bankprogramm schicken lassen und danach schreibst du den Jungs wahrscheinlich auch noch, dass dein Konto immer 0 Euro stehen würden. Und so, wir müssen jetzt auch nochmal Geld schicken, damit auch was drauf ist, dass du ordentlich testen kannst. Ja, könnt ihr mal was überweisen bitte. Es geht überhaupt keine Überweisung an.
Funktioniert das auch mit neunstelligen Zahlen?
Ja, hier wird Bank X genannt, das hatte ich auch schon mal gehört.
Bank X hab ich mal benutzt, das funktioniert irgendwie überhaupt nicht mit der Postbank zusammen mehr.
Ach, mein Kumpel Carsten hört auch zu, dieser hat er mir ja gesagt.
Ich glaub, die haben HBCI irgendwie. Die haben ja, die haben das irgendwann mit diesem TAN-Verfahren haben die. Ich wollte immer M-TAN haben, genau.
Was ist das M-TAN?
Na, M-TAN ist, dass man über SMS, dass man per SMS bekommt. Dann braucht man nämlich keine blöden TAN-Listen mit sich rumschleppen.
Das kann ja das iOutbank dann auch gleich. Da klick ich, dass sie mir eine SMS schicken sollen, die im gleichen Phone kommt und Copy und Paste, Gott sei Dank, kann man die dann rüber kopieren, ja?
Das ist jetzt eine Vermutung von dir, oder was?
Nee, aber so wird's doch dann kommen. Wenn er sagt, dass man sich die per SMS schicken lassen kann, irgendwo muss man ja sagen können, dass die geschickt werden soll. Also mit iOutbank, sag ich, schick mir die SMS.
HBCI hat M-TAN nicht unterstützt. Das war immer das Problem, darum konnte ich dann nicht mehr, konnte ich das alles nicht mehr machen.
Ja vielleicht, weiß ich nicht. Habe ich mir nicht so viele Gedanken drüber. Ich fand Konto Osterurl schon ganz gut, dass man überhaupt mal sieht, ob man auch Kohle auf dem Konto hat. Das ist für Leute, die nicht so viel Geld haben, ist das manchmal ganz hilfreich. Da gebe ich auch mal 10 Euro aus.
Mit ThinkX war ich auch nie glücklich. Also ich hab das gekauft mal für viel Geld. Das war kein schönes Programm.
So Leute.
Saldomat finde ich, rucke ich mir mal an. Saldomat wird mir gerade in den Kommentaren empfohlen.
Tja, wollen wir nochmal hier die letzten Anfragen durchklappern? Hier wird nochmal was zu Business Cases gefragt. Nochmal, ob hier irgendjemand was kauft. Nämlich ob Google Twitter kauft.
Ob Google Twitter kauft? Das ist doch mal eine spannende Frage.
Aber habt ihr gelesen, um gleich mal wieder abzulenken, aber das machen wir ja gerne hier, dass die Skype-Gründer Skype zurückkaufen wollen? Weil bei eBay das wird wohl nicht so richtig was. Sie haben es für 3,1 Milliarden an eBay verkauft damals. Und jetzt will eBay jetzt abstoßen für 1,7 Milliarden Dollar. Und zwar eventuell an die gleichen Leute zurückverkaufen. An so zwei Dänen.
Ach echt?
So macht man Geld.
Aber das ist noch nicht durch. Nee. eBay hat eingesehen, dass für sie Skype nichts ist.
Anscheinend, ja.
Und die Jungs wollen sich sozusagen ihr Business wieder zurückgeben lassen, um so auch nichts draus machen zu können.
Weil die sich denken, da ist doch ganz schön fett dick was mit. Und jetzt hätten sie es ja auch nicht so teuer verkaufen können. Die haben denen damals erklärt, was dick fett damit ist. eBay hat es nicht verstanden. Und jetzt kaufen sie es wieder zurück, weil sie denken, da ist immer noch dick fett was. Und ich denke auch, dass da noch ganz dick fett was ist.
Das glaube ich auch. Skype ist der größte Telefonanbieter mittlerweile, wo es die meisten Kunden gibt.
Aber sicherlich nicht die meisten.
Habt ihr Skype auf dem iPhone schon mal benutzt?
Ja, und es war furchtbar. Wobei das wohl bei Jailbreaks ein großes Problem sein soll.
Bei den tollen Jailbreaks. Also ich hab's noch nicht so viel benutzt, muss ich sagen. Aber ich hab auch in der Zeit noch nicht mal Telefonate geführt.
Also ich hab einen Chat gemacht, der hat, das ist wirklich ein Programm-Bug, das ich dann erstmal nicht scrollen konnte in der Liste. Das ging dann beim zweiten Mal. Und bei meinem Testanruf ist es mir jedes Mal abgestürzt, Skype. Und die Sprachqualität war gelinde gesagt eine Katastrophe. Also so richtig glücklich, obwohl ich übers heimische WLAN drin war. Andere haben überhaupt keine Probleme, aber bei mir war es wirklich ganz, ganz schlecht.
Was ich gut finde ist bei Skype, dadurch habe ich jetzt auch ein S als Icon auf meinem iPhone. Und ich warte so auf den Tag, wo ich so jeden Buchstaben dann auch mal so habe, sodass ich dann so mir so über mehrere Seiten Quickbound, Fox, Jumps Over the Lazy Dog zusammenstellen kann.
Geheime Botschaften, wie du da drin unterbringen kannst. Ja, also man kann mit so iPhone-Icons langsam schon ganz nett Gibt es das schon, dass Terroristen sich gegenseitig Nachrichten austauschen, indem sie sich Screenshots vom Doc zumailen, indem dann verschiedene Programme da drin sind?
Egal.
Bestimmt. Bestimmt. Also wird jetzt Google und Twitter kaufen. Was meinst du dann? Ich meine, wollen sie es kaufen, ist die erste Frage.
Google ist evil. Twitter ist auch ganz schön evil, was da so rüber geht an Content. Da finden die voll geil, da sehen, kaufen die das.
Aber sie lassen sich gerade nicht kaufen.
Twitter? Die brauchen es gerade nicht kaufen. Der Preis muss erst mal noch steigend. Die wissen, wir können erst mal noch selber ausbauen und dann in einem Jahr eine Milliarde mehr nehmen.
Klar.
Also das Schöne an Twitter ist natürlich...
Die haben den Biet noch nicht erreicht und die wissen das. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch wirklich so.
Was für Google sehr interessant sein könnte an Twitter ist dieses, wir kriegen raus welche... Und was wir jetzt dringend wegindizieren müssten.
Also ich meine, das ist wirklich die Informationsquelle.
Und wir haben schon Stichwörter, worum es dabei geht. Das ist glaube ich nicht schlecht für Google.
Ja, jetzt schaut ihr mich so ganz erwartungsvoll an.
Ja, du hast die Frage in den Raum geworfen. Ich dachte, du hättest jetzt eine Meinung zu dem Thema.
Nein, ein Hörer hat die Frage in den Raum geworfen. Ich hab eine Meinung dazu.
Ah, okay. Oh Gott, ich...
Ja!
Also ich glaube, Google will Twitter unbedingt auf jeden Fall kaufen. Aber ich glaube, Twitter will sie nicht lassen. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was sie sich letzten Endes davon versprechen, aber offensichtlich... Na, mehr Geld in Form von kaufen oder mehr Geld eben von wir betreiben mal unser eigenem Business. Ich meine, die Jungs sind schon mal von Google gekauft worden. Von daher sind die ja, glaube ich, das Thema schon mal durch.
Wieso?
Na, das sind doch so die so blogspot.com, blogger.com gemacht.
Und da muss man ja auch sagen, dass...
Ja, dann erklärt sich das ja, warum sie sich noch nicht kaufen lassen wollen, weil sie wissen, wie es läuft mit dem Dealing und diesmal suchen sie sich den Zeitpunkt ein bisschen besser aus.
Vielleicht sind sie ja auch schon reich genug und wollen sich das Spielzeug nicht gleich wegnehmen lassen.
Vielleicht haben sie eine Vision und wollen gar kein Geld.
Das kann natürlich sein, aber was Twitter betrifft, denke ich mal, sind sie einfach noch mittendrin und sie haben halt einfach den Vorteil, dass sie bei Twitter einfach das gesamte Internet, im Sinne von die Leute, die im Internet irgendwas gestalten, die sind halt auf Twitter und die benutzen das auch. Und es ist einfach der Ort, wo quasi die Welt miteinander diskutiert gerade. Und das ist natürlich ein Live-Content, wo sie jetzt noch den Vorteil haben, den auswerten zu können und damit einfach Dienste anbieten können, die Google derzeit nicht anbieten kann. Google kann zwar theoretisch versuchen, sich von außen das ganze Twitter-Universum reinzusinken, aber es ist schon noch etwas anderes, wenn du selber die Maschine betreibst und in Echtzeit die Dinge korrelieren kannst.
Was ist denn eigentlich, fällt mir gerade auf, Google hat ja einen eigenen Twitter-Dienst, Twitter-Clone sozusagen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wie der hieß.
Den haben sie eingestellt.
Den haben sie eingestellt. Aber die Entwickler haben den als Open-Source-Frage gegeben.
Ja, es ist keine Frage von Open-Source, es ist die Frage, wo die User sind.
Aber apropos Twitter und Google, finde ich, sollte man den zusammen schon mal erwähnen. Das ist da neben Identica bzw. Lakronika, diesen Twitter, diesen Open-Source-Twitter-Clone, jetzt noch einen zweiten gibt.
Nämlich von Google.
Ja, aber Open-Source machen heißt so viel, wie das Projekt ist gefailt.
Natürlich. Also das ist in dem Fall schon.
Ja, das ist einfach fail. Andererseits glaube ich, hat Google nicht so richtig viel Konkurrenz zu fürchten. Ihr habt ja sicherlich dieses schöne Video gesehen, was glaube ich auch vom 01-Block kurz zu sehen war, von diesem Data Center von Google, wo sie da was Modular aus Containern zusammengebaut ist. Das fand ich ja extrem beeindruckend.
Wie die Serverfarm bei Google aussieht, das ist nämlich...
Und wie der einzelne Rechner aufgebaut ist, mit der Batterie noch dran.
Genau, ohne Gehäuse.
Und dass sie nur 12 Volt machen und sich die 5 Volt daraus generieren.
War das in dem Video?
Das war in dem Video, dass die gar kein eigenes...
Im Video habe ich nicht gesehen, aber ich habe so einen Artikel gelesen, wo sie beschreiben, wie der Google-Rechner aussieht.
Nein, eigentlich das eigentlich Spannende ist, dass die nicht jeweils die 220 Volt oder 110 Volt direkt an, also dass die nicht Steckdosen haben und dann hat jeder Rechner sein eigenes Netzteil, sondern die haben außen große Trafoeinlage, die von vornherein diesen schwachen Strom liefert.
Ja klar, umsonst sollen sie dann nochmal sinnlos Wärme erzeugen. Ich weiß nicht, ist das so klar? Das macht total Sinn.
Ja, also natürlich macht das total Sinn, aber ich glaube, das ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit, auch in größeren Data Centers nicht.
Nee, in größeren Data Centers ist es deshalb keine Selbstverständlichkeit, weil halt die Kunden ihre Rechner da selber reintragen und die natürlich sowas haben. Aber bei Google ist halt alles Google. Ja, ja. Die riesige Halle, die da in diesem Video zu sehen ist. Also wirklich ein riesiger Komplex.
Da waren 40 Container, glaube ich, drinne.
So die Größenordnung.
Also so LKW-Container, so wie man sie kennt, so richtig zum Transport von...
Die Großen.
Genau. Und da waren jeweils 1000 Server, glaube ich, drinne.
Die zahl habe ich mir nicht gemerkt.
Ich nehme mir sowas ein in den Dreh.
Da passen so einige rein.
Und die Container haben dann jeweils Stromanschluss, klar, und Wasseranschluss für die Kühlung.
Genau. Fette Pipes. Draußen wird halt irgendwie ordentlich Wasser gekühlt.
Wenn sie mehr Rechenpower wollen, stellen sie einen neuen Container rein.
Dann stellen die einfach so einen Container rein. Genau. Und das ist halt das Ding. Und der Container ist natürlich für sich halt auch nochmal so eine Temperaturkapsel, in der sie eben den Airflow direkt kontrollieren. Genau. Der Airflow läuft so, dass halt die Wärme, wie war das? Genau, in der Mitte aufsteigt.
Dass die warme Luft nicht hinter den Komponenten noch mal lang läuft, sondern dass da wirklich auch, wie es halt in einem guten Gehäuse sein sollte, quasi, dass das der...
Ja, ich hab nicht mehr so ganz genau mir gemerkt, wie das da so läuft. Da wurde auch nicht so deutlich. Auf jeden Fall ist dieses Ding voll daraufhin optimiert, den Airflow optimal zu haben. Und ich glaube, unten wird dann irgendwie gekühlt und das Wasser läuft halt warm, läuft halt kalt in den Container rein und läuft warm wieder raus. So. Und dann führen sie das Ganze außerhalb der Halle raus und dort haben sie dann hier entsprechend damit tauschen.
Und eine große Kühlanlage.
Genau. Und da wird dann wieder ordentlich kaltes Wasser gemacht. Das ist schon alles irgendwie ganz schön fett. Also, mit der Power dann irgendwie mal mitzuhalten, da muss man schon einiges hinstellen.
Ja, das ist... Und ich meine, Facebook zum Beispiel, die ja 200 millionsten User jetzt gerade vor kurzem gefeiert haben, sind ja auf der Suche nach Investoren oder beziehungsweise nach Krediten, um 100 Millionen Dollar loszutreten, nur für Serverkosten. Das muss man sich auch mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Also wahrscheinlich würde es eine Firma wie Facebook guttun, mittlerweile auch eine eigene Engineering-Abteilung zu sitzen zu haben, die auch mal ein paar Server hinstellt, die das Ganze ein bisschen optimierter hinkriegen. Das ist, fand ich in dem Zusammenhang ganz interessant, dass so dieses extrem Nerdige bei Google eigene Algorithmen entwickeln. Die haben ja auch mal ewig lange Tests gemacht, bei welcher Temperatur eine Festplatte die maximale Laufleistung hat. Natürlich auch um rauszukriegen, nehme ich mal an, auf wie viel Grad sie ihre Data Center runterkühlen müssen.
Und haben festgestellt, dass die Temperatur so gar nicht so viel mit dem Plattenausfall zu tun hat.
Zum Beispiel, genau.
Sondern haben festgestellt, dass wenn die Platte erst mal einen Monat überlebt hat, dann ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie eigentlich ziemlich lange durchlauft. Also wenn Platten sterben, dann eigentlich relativ schnell.
Und dann noch mal nach drei Jahren.
Ja, dann werden sie halt richtig so alt werden, dann geht es halt schon auch mit der Fehlerrate wieder nach oben. Aber eigentlich, wenn man wirklich ganz sichere Platten haben will, dann sollte man erst mal einen sogenannten Burn-In machen, dass man die erst mal eine Woche hardcore-mäßig benutzt. Weil wenn sie das überlebt haben, dann schaffen sie auch noch mehr.
Und die werden schon wissen sehr genau, wie lange so eine Platte durchlaufen muss, etc., Das finde ich schon ganz cool bei denen.
Also mir gehen jetzt die Themen aus. Würde ich sagen, verschieben wir mal den Rest auf die nächsten zwei Wochen.
Im Chat wird gerade über Twitter-Klienz diskutiert. Das können wir natürlich beim nächsten Mal. Also es wird Dennis dann nicht so interessieren, aber welche Twitter-Klienz es denn mittlerweile so für einen Mac gibt. Wäre nochmal eine spannende Sache, oder?
Du kannst dann ja mal vortragen.
Dann werde ich mal ein bisschen was vortragen zu dem Thema.
Dennis noch irgendwas schönes beitragen? Nein? Dennis mag nicht mehr. Jungs, das war's. Heute machen wir mal nicht so eine lange Sendung. Das ist der letzte Mal auch wirklich.
Beim letzten Mal hatten wir auch einfach toll viele Themen.
Ach, wir reden schon wieder viel zu lange.
Wie viel haben wir denn?
Na so zwei Stunden sind wir schon dabei.
Aber es war doch ein ganz entspannter, wir sind ja auch alle noch ein bisschen...
Wir würden nach einem Hörertreffen gefragt.
Ja.
Wollen wir mal ein Hörertreffen machen?
Wenn du mitmachst, Dennis? Vielleicht. Wir denken da mal drüber nach.
Wir denken mal drüber nach und schreiben dann wahrscheinlich entweder melden wir uns beim nächsten Mal oder schreiben was ins Blog.
Genau.
Wir haben da so ein Webblog unter mobilemacs.de. Das wissen viele von euch nicht.
Leider wissen wir ja schon viel aus. Das wäre ich würde ja ein Hörertreffen voll gut finden, wo wir so alle hingehen und niemand weiß, wer es jetzt wirklich ist.
Ah, du meinst so mit Weihnachtsmannmasken?
Nee, aber dass alle da sind und so über mobile, wie heißt man, mobilemacs quatschen wollen. Aber keiner weiß, dass wir drei jetzt die Jungs sind, sondern das halt.
Ich glaube, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Wir haben da so ein Merkmal, an dem man uns relativ gut erkennt, sobald wir was sagen.
Dich erkennt doch niemand.
Und Stimme vor allen Dingen.
Ja, Dennis, und du brauchst ja dann nur irgendwie in deiner Kongress-Logo-verkrampften Haltung auf dem Stuhl mit deinem Laptop zu sitzen und sobald du deinen Macbook aufklämpfst. Genau. Und dein Admin wird dich auch sofort verraten. Und natürlich die schwarze Maske und der Mantel.
Also alle, die sich letztes Mal beschwert haben, die müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt erst mal return of the Jedi gucken. Ist ja klar, da wird Darth Vader die Maske abgenommen. Dann wissen sie, warum man manchmal so ein bisschen schniefen muss.
Und dann wissen sie auch, wie du aussiehst beim nächsten Hörer-Treffen. So, liebe Leute, das war's. Wir machen jetzt hier Schluss.
Bis in zwei Wochen, oder?
Genau, Winke, Winke, bis bald.